programming throwdown episode 89 from combat to code with the jerome hardaway take it away jason hey everyone as patrick said, we have Jerome with us. Jerome is a combat veteran, and he's started his career out in the military, and then after that has moved on, and we'll kind of listen about his story and also the amazing work he's doing with a group called Vets Who Code. And along the way, he'll be able to tell a lot of us something which I know a lot of people out there are interested in, which is how do we sort of retool? Maybe we've done one career for five years, 10 years, 30 years, and we just get this passion to get into software development, get into engineering. How do we go about realizing you know that dream and that's what we have uh jerome here to talk about today uh roger that hey guys how you doing it's a very uh very good day and like awesome to
Programming Throwdown 第89期，从战场到代码，嘉宾是 Jerome Hardaway，Jason 请开始。嘿，大家好，正如 Patrick 所说，今天 Jerome 和我们在一起。Jerome 是一位退伍军人，他的职业生涯始于军队，之后又转型了。我们将了解他的故事，以及他通过一个名为 Vets Who Code 的组织所做的了不起的工作。在此过程中，他将告诉我们许多人感兴趣的事情，那就是我们该如何进行职业转型？也许我们已经在某个行业工作了五年、十年、三十年，但突然产生了进入软件开发或工程领域的激情。我们该如何实现那个梦想？这就是今天请 Jerome 来谈论的话题。收到，嘿伙计们，你们好吗？今天真是个好日子，很高兴见到你们，谢谢邀请我。
meet you guys so thank you for having me cool so why don't you start by kind of walking us through, you know, did you go in kind of through university to school? Did you go from high school to the to the military? What was that transition like? How about military to civilian, civilian to coder? Like kind of walk us through that whole story. Roger that. It's kind of like military to veteran. Like you're not you're never like back to never back to civilian. You're a civilian, military, veteran, and then while being a veteran, you're a programmer.
酷，那么你先给我们介绍一下，你是通过大学进入军队的吗？还是从高中直接参军的？那种转变是怎样的？从军队到平民，再从平民到程序员，这种转变过程是怎样的？给我们讲讲整个故事吧。收到。这就像从军人到退伍军人一样。你永远回不到“平民”状态。你是平民、军人、退伍军人，而在成为退伍军人之后，你又是一名程序员。
I see. Okay. when I was a wee glass. I ended up going straight into the Air Force from high school. I actually was at a performing arts high school, and I had a scholarship to go to college, but it was in something. I didn't have real passion, and I couldn't see myself, you know, in orchestra and piano and stuff forever, and doing crazy things with that so i ended up opting for the military and one of the things that kind of happened was i wanted to actually do something in the war on terror was really at its apex at that point so even though i had high
我明白了。好的。当我还是个小伙子的时候，我高中毕业就直接加入了空军。其实我当时在一所表演艺术高中，本来有奖学金可以上大学，但那不是我真正热爱的领域，我无法想象自己永远在管弦乐队里拉琴、弹钢琴，做那些疯狂的事情。所以我最终选择了参军。当时发生的一件事是，我想在反恐战争中做点什么，那时战争正处于顶峰，所以尽管我的分数很高，
enough scores i chose to go towards the security forces route. In retrospect, it probably was a silly thing to do. But when you're 17 and, you know, hocked up on testosterone. So what was this like around 2001 or what? Oh, no, this is around 2004. 2004. Okay. Yeah, I graduated in 2004.
我还是选择了安全部队这条路。回想起来，这可能有点傻。但当你 17 岁，满脑子都是荷尔蒙的时候，就是这样。那是 2001 年左右吗？哦，不，那是 2004 年左右。2004 年。好的。是的，我 2004 年毕业。
I'm old. I'm not that old. So that was, yeah, I mean, that's true. So September 11th is what I was thinking of. But then, you know, after that, there was just, you know, there's this sort of this escalation, right? And so when you were getting into it, it was still, you know, it was really hot. It was really heating up it was really yeah the it was a we were transitioning from the way we used to do combat operations in the military
我老了。我还没那么老。所以，是的，那是真的。我当时想到的是 9 月 11 日。但后来，你知道，在那之后，局势升级了，对吧？所以当你加入的时候，局势依然非常紧张，非常激烈。是的，我们正在从军队过去进行作战行动的方式，
which more regimented to this more dynamic um dynamic flow when i look at it from like what i'm doing in tech now to how we're doing military it was very very unique on how similar those things were because it it was like agile methodologies and combine just had long military names for using aef cycles and things like that when you call aef cycle we call a sprint right uh some stuff like that so it was very very unique in how the as i've gone from you know how as i went from rookie to you know being military and few deployments and in under my belt and uh as i'm in tech how the not how that skills and experience transfer has continuously like you know shifted so you know just how things are different but yes I went in security forces and did a few I did it went to Iraq from the camp uka all
那种更严谨的方式，转变为这种更动态的流程。当我从现在从事的技术工作来看我们当时在军队的做法时，发现它们非常相似。就像敏捷方法论和看板，只是军队里有很长的术语，比如 AEF 周期之类的。当你提到 AEF 周期时，我们称之为“冲刺”，对吧？类似这样的事情。所以，当我从菜鸟变成一名有几次部署经验的军人，再到现在的技术人员，这种技能和经验的迁移一直在不断变化。是的，我加入了安全部队，去过伊拉克，在 Camp Bucca，
right when they're gonna stand none close location doesn't have a name yet but we were there didn't have a. Then South Korea and a couple of other crazy full deployments that I don't talk about because I don't want to get in trouble. We don't need someone kicking down the door right now. I don't want anybody in a suit asking me any more questions for a very long time. Totally. Yeah, so I was there i was in uh operation
当时那个地方甚至还没有名字。然后去了韩国，还有几次疯狂的部署，我不谈论这些，因为我不想惹麻烦。我们不需要现在有人破门而入。我不想再让任何穿西装的人问我更多问题了。完全理解。是的，我参加了“持久自由行动”和“伊拉克自由行动”。
doer freedom operation iraqi freedom and once i ended up uh decided i was gonna leave the military in 2009 it was under this uh guys that you know db 214 was going to be my magic ticket what is that so i don't actually know what that is the magic the dd you know magic the magic ticket is a joke about willie wonka right yeah that's how veterans treat their dd 214 basically dd 214 is the paperwork that you get when you leave the military that states that hey you have fulfilled your service in the military is you know it's your magic ticket because like once you have your successful term if you're honorably discharged um it basically opens you up to all your veteran benefits like gi bill um what gi bill veteran housing loans stuff like that
当我 2009 年决定离开军队时，当时的想法是 DD-214 表格将是我的“魔法门票”。那是什么？我其实不知道那是什么。魔法……DD……你知道，魔法门票是关于威利·旺卡的笑话，对吧？是的，这就是退伍军人对待 DD-214 的方式。基本上，DD-214 是你离开军队时收到的文件，证明你已经履行了服役义务。这是你的“魔法门票”，因为一旦你成功服役并光荣退伍，它基本上就为你打开了所有退伍军人福利的大门，比如《退伍军人权利法案》（GI Bill）、退伍军人住房贷款之类的。
uh veteran business loans stuff like you know it's all those systems that you know it's the magic ticket though hey yo i can go out here and do amazing things what they did not tell me was that at the time when i was getting out because you know the bubble thing is real and there's no uh more concrete bubble than the military bubble uh so they didn't tell me when i was leaving in the military i said there was this thing called a great recession going on yeah i had no idea what was going that that was i was like you know skipping out the gate and what was going on when i when i was out i really you know i was getting this thank you for your service but your skills aren't – we don't have anything for you or you don't have the skills for it. So just to give some back, what did you go into the Air Force to do?
退伍军人商业贷款之类的。你知道，所有这些系统，这就是“魔法门票”。嘿，我可以出去做伟大的事情了。他们没有告诉我的是，当时我退伍时，因为“泡沫”是真实存在的，而且没有比军事泡沫更坚固的泡沫了。所以他们没告诉我，当我离开军队时，正值大衰退时期。是的，我完全不知道发生了什么。我当时就像是蹦蹦跳跳地走出大门，但我出来后，真的，我得到的只是“感谢你的服役，但我们不需要你”或者“你不具备相关技能”。那么，为了背景补充，你加入空军是做什么的？
I was security forces. Essentially, it's a combat career field, combat security career field. Got it. combat security career field uh yeah so uh when you spend you know half a decade carrying an m4 carbine and a nine millimeter you know when you get out of the civilian for um in the civilian sector uh unless you're doing that there's not really a lot of jobs that are open up to you yeah so yeah so i was 2000 so so I'm 2009, 2010. I'm looking around. I'm like, yo, I'm being told that, you know, thank you for my service, but you're essentially useless in the civilian sector.
我是安全部队。本质上，这是一个战斗职业领域，战斗安全职业领域。明白了。战斗安全职业领域。是的，当你花了五年时间扛着 M4 卡宾枪和 9 毫米手枪时，当你进入平民领域，除非你从事相关工作，否则真的没有多少工作机会。所以，是的，那是 2009 年、2010 年。我环顾四周，心想，嘿，我被告知“感谢你的服役”，但在平民领域我基本上是个废人。
Don't like that. That sucks. What do I do to fix it? I happened to see this commercial on Facebook about, like, learning how to code. They had some guy that was like, I think he was in the Miami heat. He was a like tall, tall guy. He was,
我不喜欢那样。这太糟糕了。我该怎么解决它？我碰巧在 Facebook 上看到一个关于学习编程的广告。里面有个人，我想他是迈阿密热火队的。他是个很高的人，
he was a computer science major as well, but he played basketball. Now they had Mark Zuckerberg in it. And will I am that I do remember that annoying code. Or a commercial will, will I am in it? You're like, you know, I never saw that, but I can, with Will.i.am in it? You're like, shut up.
他也是计算机科学专业的，但他打篮球。现在他们让马克·扎克伯格和 Will.i.am 参与其中。我确实记得那个烦人的代码广告。或者有 Will.i.am 的广告？你就像是，你知道，我从没见过那个，但 Will.i.am 在里面？你就像是，闭嘴。
You know, I never saw that, but I'm picturing in my head, you know, somebody with a really high-pitched autotune voice, you know, telling me to learn C++. You know, it's like, I don't know. It was a high pitch, but Will.i.am is just annoying. So, please, Will.i.am, if you're listening, no hard feelings. Don't hit me, IRL so yeah so i was like what is this programming stuff i actually happened to have had a book that i picked up randomly while i was overseas i just had it with me about databases and i was
你知道，我从没见过那个，但我脑海中浮现出一个人用那种高音调的自动调音声音，告诉我学习 C++。你知道，我不知道。那是高音调，但 Will.i.am 就是很烦人。所以，拜托，Will.i.am，如果你在听的话，别往心里去。别在现实生活中打我。所以，是的，我当时想，这些编程的东西是什么？我碰巧在海外时随手捡到一本书，是关于数据库的，我当时就
like what is this and i was doing some research this book, decided I was going to go through this SQL stuff that was in this book. About six, seven months later, had my first job working at-profit and working there as a quote-unquote marketing assistant but if you ever worked in the business of non-profits if you're the youngest person at the non-profit you end up handling all the technology stuff because it's just like non-profits are essentially like uh well classical non-profits as i like to say they're essentially like, well, classical nonprofits, as I like to say, they're essentially like going to your grandmother's house or your grandpa's house. Like, you know,
想，这是什么？我做了一些研究，决定学习书里的 SQL 内容。大约六七个月后，我得到了第一份工作，在一家非营利组织工作，职位是所谓的“营销助理”。但如果你在非营利组织工作过，如果你是那里最年轻的人，你最终会处理所有的技术事务，因为非营利组织本质上就像……嗯，我喜欢称之为“古典非营利组织”，它们本质上就像去你奶奶或爷爷家。就像，你知道，
you need to like, you need to already know the wifi password or they don't know how to work the VCR. The VCR is blinking 12. I was just thinking that, you know, I go to my parents' house and it's still doing that. My dad thinks it's a Zenith 12 and I just don't, he's seven old i don't want to break it to him you know but yeah i mean i don't
你需要已经知道 Wi-Fi 密码，否则他们根本不知道怎么用录像机。录像机的时间一直在闪烁 12 点。我刚才就在想，我去我父母家时，它还在闪。我爸以为那是 Zenith 12，我只是不想……他 70 多岁了，我不想打破他的幻想，你知道，但是的，我不想
want to tell him that i'm afraid if i set the time that he's just gonna you know end up wandering somewhere yeah so uh so i was there thinking i was going to be doing a lot of design social media marketing things like that and they were like hey you you're young fix our website and i looked at this website it was like something that was outside of like jurassic park like it was still like a 90s style website like geocities the flowers follow the follow the mouse cursor yeah it's horrible just sad like sadness all. So I spent three months going through that, learning PHP, because this is, I think, this is 2011, 2012. So this is before the, quote, unquote, big JavaScript boom. We haven't, you know, Node.js hasn't, like, dropped, dropped.
告诉他，我怕如果我帮他调好时间，他最终会迷路。所以，我在那里以为我会做很多设计、社交媒体营销之类的事情，结果他们说：“嘿，你很年轻，修修我们的网站。”我看了看那个网站，简直像是《侏罗纪公园》之外的东西，还是 90 年代的风格，像 GeoCities，花朵跟着鼠标光标转。是的，太可怕了，简直令人悲伤。所以我花了三个月时间学习 PHP，因为那是 2011 年、2012 年。那是所谓的“JavaScript 大爆发”之前。Node.js 还没有真正火起来。
Like, you know, when he dropped Node.js, it was like when Drake dropped his mixtape, right? We all went like, everybody went crazy. So you know that analogy. So we were doing that with PHP and a CMS, content management system. I'm trying not to use acronyms because some of the people who are listening may be students. And I was like writing the worst php code you could imagine had no ideas about styles any of that stuff uh learning color theory and design psychology and ux um all on the fly really enjoyed it really loved it found out i kind of started finding
就像，你知道，当他发布 Node.js 时，就像 Drake 发布他的混音带一样，对吧？我们都疯了。所以你知道那个类比。所以我们当时用 PHP 和 CMS（内容管理系统）做这些。我尽量不用缩写，因为有些听众可能是学生。我当时写的是你能想象到的最烂的 PHP 代码，根本不懂样式之类的东西。学习色彩理论、设计心理学和用户体验，全都是在工作中现学的。我真的很享受，真的很喜欢，我发现我开始找到
that my passion was you know ui and u UX engineering from that, you know, experience. In three months, I had the first iteration of a, I guess, back then, modern web. But if you look at, like, what modern web is now, like, now that's an ancient artifact, right? It's really interesting how, in hindsight, you could kind of put the pieces together. So you have this background in music, which is about sort of art and symmetry and then you have this whole sort of experience in the military and then you come back and you're doing web design again kind of focused on front end and and you know being able to build sites with symmetry and art and stuff like that well yeah see um i think there's a book
我的激情所在，那就是从那次经历中获得的 UI 和 UX 工程。三个月内，我完成了现代网页的第一个迭代。但如果你看看现在的“现代网页”，那简直是古代文物了，对吧？回想起来，你能把这些碎片拼凑起来，这真的很有趣。所以你有音乐背景，那是关于艺术和对称的，然后你有在军队的经历，回来后你又做网页设计，专注于前端，并且能够构建具有对称性和艺术感的网站。嗯，是的，你看，我认为有一本书
out there and they they talk about like the most successful people um in industries like the elon musk of the world they have a unique ability called uh skills transfer challenge transfer whatever you want to call it in which they're picking up things and they're applying instead of trying to learn it from a whole different point of view they're using up things and they're applying instead of trying to learn it from a whole different point of view they're using what they learned in their past and doing a knowledge transfer of those skills to apply it to the other things that's something that helped me with learning how to program i um i kind of broke down like when i was in the military, I broke down how learning my M4A1, like how you would break down learning sheet music.
谈到了行业中最成功的人，比如埃隆·马斯克之类的人，他们有一种独特的能力，叫做“技能迁移”或“挑战迁移”，无论你怎么称呼它。他们不是试图从一个全新的角度去学习，而是应用他们过去学到的东西，进行知识迁移，将其应用到其他事情上。这对我学习编程很有帮助。我在军队时，把学习 M4A1 的过程拆解开来，就像拆解学习乐谱一样。
And then when I was learning how to code, I broke down the understanding of front-end development or full-stack development now, the way you would break down our understanding of a weapon. You know, and that's how I teach my veterans as well. I break it down from the concept of, you, we're starting the most basic concept. So it's like terminal and Like so I'll teach a command line or terminal then I'm teaching how to use git then while we're doing git We're also going to be learning how to use git flow and then while we're using git flow
当我学习编程时，我把对前端开发或现在的全栈开发的理解拆解开来，就像拆解对武器的理解一样。你知道，这也是我教我的退伍军人的方式。我从最基本的概念开始拆解。比如终端，所以我先教命令行或终端，然后教如何使用 Git，在学习 Git 的同时，我们也会学习如何使用 Git Flow，而在使用 Git Flow 的同时，
We're also going to be learning Kanban and then once we move on from that We're going to start we're going to move on into the Chrome browser. Then once we go from Chrome browser, we're going to also start doing the debugger. And now that we're doing that, now we're going to go to our text editor because text editor uses the same tools that the debugger use, such as console and things of that nature. And from now we're in text editor, now let's start learning HTML. Now let's start learning CSS. Now let's start learning JavaScript.ml now let's start on css now let's start learning javascript right yeah so yeah so that's how i've been you know that's how i train that's how you know that's how i train myself that's how i teach you know very um you know a
我们也会学习看板（Kanban）。一旦我们掌握了这些，我们就会进入 Chrome 浏览器。然后从 Chrome 浏览器开始，我们也会开始使用调试器。现在我们正在做这些，我们要去我们的文本编辑器，因为文本编辑器使用与调试器相同的工具，比如控制台之类的。现在我们在文本编辑器里了，让我们开始学习 HTML。现在让我们开始学习 CSS。现在让我们开始学习 JavaScript。是的，这就是我的训练方式，这就是我训练自己的方式，这就是我教人的方式，一种非常严谨的方式，这样我就可以专注于基础知识，每一项技能都建立在自身之上，而且你总是使用该技能去做别的事情，对吧？所以这就是帮助我不断推动职业生涯前进的东西。快进到……是的，那么，关于技术领域的一个大问题，我认为这可能比技术领域更广泛，但它目前对技术领域的影响最大，那就是没有真正稳固的认证体系。所以，在很多地方，你必须获得四年制学位，学习艺术史、社会学之类的东西，有些人欣赏这些，有些人不欣赏，
very regimented way so that way you know i can focus on a fundamentals and each skill grows upon each um itself and you know you're always using that skill like to do something else right so that's just uh basically what helped me you know keep moving my career forward and things of that nature fast forward to yes so so what about like you know one of the big issues i think in in tech and this might be even more broad it's probably more broad than tech but it affects tech i think the most right now is that there isn't really a solid accreditation and so and so for many places what you have to do is you have to get this four-year degree where you learn you know art history and sociology and these things which which you know some people appreciate and some people don't,
但它们与构建一个稳固的网站无关，对吧？所以并不是每个人都想走学术路线进入网页设计或任何类似的领域。目前，技术的职业学校理念还处于婴儿阶段，对吧？所以我认为这是退伍军人处于劣势的领域之一，因为人们只是在寻找那个证书。所以这是一个大问题。是的，你会告诉雇主什么？你知道，有什么东西是你可以让很多退伍军人围绕在一起，并说这是几乎每个退伍军人都能带来的独特技能组合吗？你在军队中学到的哪些东西是任何技术雇主都非常乐意拥有的？
but they're not relevant to being able to build a solid website, right? So not everyone necessarily wants to go the academic route to get into web design or any field like that. And at the moment, you know, the whole trade school idea of tech is just still kind of at the sort of baby phase, right? And so I think this is one of those areas where people in the military who have sort of this kind of culture and that knowledge base are at this disadvantage because people are just kind of looking for that certificate right so that is a big problem yeah what would you tell employers um you know that something that that sort of you know you can like wrap a lot of military folks around and say this is some unique skill set that you know just about everyone from the military, just about every veteran can bring to the table. What are some things that you kind of learned in the military that any tech employer would really love to have, right?
专业精神，在情况发生时保持冷静，即使你不知道发生了什么，也要注意细节。这些都是你在编程或任何技术领域所需要的。你在军队的前三个月就被教导了这些，因为我们非常重视细节，因为在我们的工作中，生命处于危险之中。所以，当人们在 Facebook 工作时，你的细节疏忽可能会损失很多钱，而在军队中，你的细节疏忽可能会让某人付出生命的代价。所以这种迁移……
Professionalism, being calm when there's a situation going on, even if you don't know what's going on being you know attention to detail those are all things that we come that you need in programming or anything in tech that you know you're taught like in the first three months in the military because you know we hold attention to detail very high because you know our in our jobs lives are at stake so you know while people are you know you're at facebook and your attention to detail may cost a lot of money you know in the military your lack of attention to detail may cost someone um you know may cost someone their life so that transfer of that you know
这很有效。我认为你确实说中了我要告诉雇主和学生的大部分要点。当你提到技能组合时，我告诉人们这是一种技能。你投入多少，就会得到多少。你知道，这就是编程的本质。你必须……这和锻炼没什么不同。这和你想跳芭蕾、想学钢琴、想学画画、想学开车没什么不同。现在，我们有多少人上次开车时还在思考开车这件事？是的，这已经成为潜意识了。是的，因为你一直在做。你多年来每天都在重复相同的概念和动作。编程也是一样。
that works well i think you hit the nail on a lot of the things that I tell both employers and students right on the head, though. When you said skill set, I tell people it's a skill. What you get into it is what you'll get out of it. You know, that's just the nature of the piece of programming. You have to, you know, it's no different than, you know, working out. It's no different than if you wanted to do ballet, if you wanted to learn how to play the piano, if you want to learn how to paint, if you want to, you know, just same way with driving. Like now, how many of us was the last time you thought about driving when you were driving? Yeah, it's just unconscious. Yes, because you've been doing it forever. You've been repeating the same concepts and same maneuvers every day for years. That's the same way programming is.
对。所以这是一场游戏。世界冠军不是因为他们去拿了证书才成为冠军，或者世界上最好的综合格斗选手，他们不是因为拿了黑带就停止了。他们之所以是最好的，是因为他们每天都在训练。你知道，我让大多数加入的人听的第一本书，或者说一旦你从训练中的士兵变成社区成员，并且在产品方面做事情时，我让他们听的第一件事就是 Jocko Willink 的《纪律等于自由：实战手册第一卷》。是的，这是我的最爱。他的章节之一是“每一天都是周一”，这意味着你必须每天都到场，准备好全力以赴。
Right. So it's a game to game out. World champions aren't made because they, you know, go and get a certificate or, you know, the best mixed martial artists in the world. They are not the best because they got a black belt and they stopped. They are the best because they kept training every day. You know, a favorite. I'm the first book I make. Most people who once they say join are I guess are what it's not truly an executive team it's like once you go from troop in
没有休息日。这就是我看待编程的方式。你必须学习。像这样的事情。我试着告诉人们，在这些方面，我没有任何特别之处。我试着告诉人们，在编程方面，我没有任何特别之处。我不觉得自己是什么摇滚明星程序员。我想我入行大概五年了，五年、六年吧。我是一个拿着“程序员”头衔领薪水的专业人士。
training to like community member and you're doing things in the program and the product on the product side first thing I haven't listened to is Jocko Willink's discipline equals freedom Equals Freedom Field Manual Volume 1. Yeah, it's my favorite. One of his chapters is like every day is Monday, which means you have to arrive and show up every day and be ready to give it your best.
如果回到我刚开始写代码的时候，时间更长，也许七、八、九年。但是，你知道，五年拿到……哦，是的，他绝对是个程序员。他正式是个程序员。我觉得当你拿到支票上写着你是程序员时，你就是个程序员。我知道有些人会说“当你决定自己是开发者时，你就是开发者”。我则认为，当有人付钱让我做这件事时，我就是开发者。
There are no dates off. And that's how I look at programming. You have to learn. Things like that. I try to tell people I'm not special in any way, shape, or form when it things like that. I try to tell people I'm not special in any way, shape or form in terms of programming. I don't feel like I'm some, you know, rock star programmer. I've been in the game, I think, five years, five, six years, maybe. I'm a professional that's getting paid with the term programmer in my title.
是的，这很有道理。我认为完全正确，人们每天都在练习那项技能。我正在尝试为了健康原因多做运动。如果有人看过我的照片，我是个瘦子，我不会成为职业健美运动员，我几乎举不动东西。我去健身房时有点尴尬，但这没关系。但我当时在看一个职业健美运动员的视频。
If I go back to when I first started writing code, longer than that, maybe seven, eight, nine years. But, you know, five years of getting, you know, oh, yes, he is definitely a programmer. He's officially a programmer. Like, I feel like you're a programmer when the check says you're a programmer. So, like, that's just, like, I know there's people, like, you're a developer when you decide that you're a developer. I'm like, I'm a developer when someone pays me to do it.
他说，我每天都去健身房。他说，圣诞节我在健身房，生日那天我也在健身房。我认为生活中有很多事情，你开始时处于一种“无意识的无知”状态。你甚至不知道该知道什么。然后你学习，好的，我需要学习，比如 Node.js。
Like, that's how I felt yeah that makes sense i think it's totally right that that that you know the people you know practice that that skill every single day like i uh i'm trying to get more into exercise for health reasons i'm not if anyone's seen a picture of me i'm a skinny guy i'm not going to be you know professional bodybuilder i can barely uh uh you know lift stuff it's a little embarrassing when i go to the gym but that's fine be, you know, professional bodybuilder. I can barely, uh, uh, you know, lift stuff. It's a little embarrassing when I go to the gym, but that's fine. Um, but yeah, I was watching this video of this person who, uh, um, what is a professional bodybuilder.
所以我设定了这个目标。那是 Node.js。我不知道它是什么。我需要弄清楚它。然后你说，好的，我学会了。我可以写一些基本的东西。你知道，我有一台电脑总是开着 Google 或 Stack Overflow 帮我，另一台电脑是我写代码的地方，或者两块屏幕。然后你达到了“无意识的理解”状态，你可以直接打开文本编辑器，甚至不需要语法高亮，就开始写代码，
And, uh, he said, you know, I go to the gym every single day. He said, you know, on Christmas, I'm at the gym. He's on my birthday. I'm at the gym. And, um, I think that's, you know, there's so many things in life where you kind of need to, you start off in this state of like, let's say, unconscious ignorance. You don't know even what to know. Then you learn, okay, I need to learn, let's say, Node.js.
因为你已经做了太久了。就像任何技能一样，我叔叔是个木匠，他也会讲类似的故事。是的，我认为这需要大量的努力，但最优秀的人学会了如何从每一小时中获得最大收益，并有奉献精神投入所有这些时间。
So now I set this bar. There's Node.js. I don't know what it is. I need to figure it out. And then you say, okay, I've learned it. I can write some basic things. You know, I have one computer that's always on Google or Stack Overflow helping me and the other computer is where I write my code or two screens. And then you get to that state of unconscious understanding where you can just open up, you know, a text editor. It doesn't even have to have the highlighting and just start writing code
是的，你说得完全对。这就是为什么我告诉我们的入门级学员，以及当我与招聘经理交谈时，我说，你会从一个表现出工作意愿的人身上得到更多，而不是从一个有天赋的人身上得到更多。因为那些人，特别是那些愿意的人，我们做事的方式是有预备工作的。这是我能找到的最低指标。没有花哨的代码挑战，什么都没有。我们有预备工作，你需要做这些事情，
because you've been doing it for so long. And just like any skill, my uncle was a carpenter and he would tell similar stories about that skill. And yeah, I think it takes a ton of effort, but the best people learn to sort of get the most out of kind of every hour and have the dedication to put in all of those hours
才能获得面试机会，成为编码的一员。你会惊讶地发现有多少人不想做这些。而那些做了的人，他们最终会进来，变得非常成功并实现他们的目标。嗯，那是因为我们做的第一件事就是说，嘿，你必须工作。你知道那句名言吗？成功在人们看来很像工作。这就是为什么人们不幸运。在 VWC 也是同样的理念。我试着让他们知道。
yeah you're absolutely right that's why i tell um from even from our entry level on our program to you when i'm talking to hiring managers i'm like you're going to get more out of somebody that shows a willingness to work than someone that has an aptitude for it. Because those people who, particularly those people who are willing, like the way we do it is that we have pre-work. It's the lowest metric that I think I could find. There's no fancy code challenges, nothing like that. We have pre-work where you need to do this stuff
我每天都在写代码。我在读代码。我在看关于代码的视频。我最喜欢的，Google 推荐的东西。没有什么是我打不出来的，Google 都会推荐与代码相关的东西。我总是在 Medium 上。我总是在 GitHub 上。我总是在 Stack Overflow 上。Front End Masters 已经成为……你知道，我有这种“让你的伙伴成为你的英雄”的哲学，
in order to get an interview to be part of it to code. And you'd be amazed how many people don't want to do that. And the ones who do it, they end up coming in and getting to become super successful and reaching their goals. Well, that's because the first thing that we do is we're saying, hey, you have to work. You know, there's that saying that success looks, you know, looks a lot like work to people. And that's why people, they're not lucky. And it's the same concept at VWC. I try to let them know.
你的英雄，你的伙伴，对吧？所以 Front End Masters 多年来一直是我的首选。现在我是 Front End Masters 的忠实拥护者，他们也成了我工作的忠实粉丝，现在他们正在给我的学员提供免费的 Front End Masters 账号。所以这很酷，我能够传递这一点。但我就是这样一个坚定的粉丝，我总是学习，总是进步。和我董事会成员的理念一样，我让 Seth Short 成为我引入的第一批董事会成员之一，我是他最大的粉丝，因为我通过艰难的方式学习了 Ruby，通过艰难的方式学习了 Python，
Every day I am writing code. I'm reading code. I'm watching videos on code. My favorites, Google recommends stuff. There's nothing I can't type that Google recommends something, Google will recommend something code related to it. Um, I'm always on medium. I'm always on GitHub. I'm always on stack overflow. Uh, front end masters has become, I mean, you know, I have this philosophy of making your homies, your heroes, I mean,
诸如此类。我们最终成为了朋友，然后他加入了我的董事会。因为我总是试图将这些技能融入我的生活，甚至我的房子。我想我有 12 个灯，我在这里设置了 Google Action，使用 JavaScript，然后我有 Google Home 设置，我正在处理所有这些东西。所以这是一种语音控制吗？就像《星际迷航》那样，说“打开客厅”，它就自动执行了？正在想名字。我们选了 Hyperion，
your heroes, your homies, right? So front end masters is like my go-to for years. And now I'm such a big, proponent of front-end masters and that that they became a big fan of my work and now they're giving uh my troops free front-end masters accounts right so it's like that yeah so like it's cool that i'm able to pass that on but like that's how steadfast steadfast of a fan i am i am of always learning always improving um same concept with like my board members i have made you know set shot he was one of my first board members that i brought on and he i was his biggest fan because i learned ruby the hard way learn python the hard
但我们还在找一个酷的名字，但有很多语音激活的东西。我们还有，我们正在使用一个……它叫什么来着？像这些物联网（IoT）的东西，总是从我脑子里溜走。哦，像……这些物联网东西总是让我头疼。我们正在做它。
way things like that we end up becoming friends and then go to join my board like these are because like i am always trying to ingrain these skills in my board like these are because like i am always trying to ingrain these skills in my life like even my house like i have like um i think 12 of the lights and here i have google action set up using javascript and then yeah i have google home set up and i'm having i'm working on all this stuff so is it like a voice thing where you say you know like star trek turn on the living room and it just does it? Trying to figure out a name for it. We picked Hyperion,
我知道那个……不是 Arduino，是另一个。有 Raspberry Pi。Raspberry Pi，对了。我们正在拿一个 Raspberry Pi，我们还要做一个智能镜子，我们要把智能镜子连接到我们用 JavaScript 构建的 API 上，
but like it does like, we're trying to find a cool name for it, but it's a lot of voice activated stuff. We have also, we're using a, what is it called? Like these IOT things, like always get away from me. Oh, like the, a what is it called? These IoT things always get away from me. We're making it.
以及我们正在使用的 API……有很多东西，我只是试着把我正在学习和试图掌握的东西融入到我生活的每一个层面，对吧？这就是我试图推动我的学员去做的事情。即使当他们做最终项目时，他们问我该做什么，我说，你就是产品，你就是项目。你太有趣了，如果你不有趣，Facebook 就不会对所有人免费，他们也不会通过广告做所有事情，对吧？所以我说，你很有趣。但看看你自己，你对自己来说很无聊，因为你每天都是你。但当你拆解开来，比如这周，我们新一期课程的第四周。他们必须做的一件事
I know the... Not Arduino, the other one. There's Raspberry Pi. Raspberry Pi, there you go. We're taking a Raspberry Pi and we're going to make a smart mirror as well and we're going to connect a smart mirror to the APIs that we're building in JavaScript and APIs that we're going to connect a smart mirror to the apis or building a javascript and
是写一个 JavaScript 对象，他们必须在那个对象中写下关于他们自己的属性值，对吧？所以关于他们的一切。我当时想，有些人有这些巨大的对象，叫做“你”或他们的名字，他们正在做……比如一个学员有“你”，他们的对象有 100 行长，所以我说，是的，我喜欢它。现在我们要教你如何把这些变量放入函数、点 map、
apis that we're using like we're there's so much stuff that i'm just like i try to incorporate the things that i'm learning and trying to master to every level of my lifestyle right and that's why i try to push to my troops like you know even like when they do their final projects they ask me what they should do i'm like you you're the product you're the project like there's you're so much you're so interesting if you weren't interesting uh facebook wouldn't be free to everybody and they wouldn't be like doing everything by ads right so i was like you're interesting like but look at yourself like you're boring to you because you're you every day but when you break down like i make like um this week We did, it's our fourth week of a new cohort. And one of the things that they had to do
点 reduce，所有这些东西，这样你就可以操作这些数据，关于你，能够讲故事，并把这些信息放在你想要的地方。这将是你的第一步。现在你正在使用这个巨大的对象，然后你将转向使用 JSON 对象，而不是这个巨大的对象。这简直是个怪物。你不应该在生产级代码中这样做。然后我们将转向使用 API，因为这是自然的演变，
was they had to write a JavaScript object and they had to write in that object, a property value of everything that they, about them, right? So everything they want about them. And I was like, so some of these people have these giant objects called you or their name and they're doing like like one troop has you and their object is like 100 lines long so i'm like yeah i love it so now we're going to teach you how to put that variables do functions dot map dot
对吧？但是你……是的，非常酷。所以这就是我总是试图推动他们以这种概念思考自己的方式。那么，给我们介绍一下 Vets Who Code。你是一名开发者，在什么时刻你说……我想……这可能一直都在你脑海里，但在某个时刻你对自己说，你知道，作为一种渠道，或者是一个真正能让其他人起步的人，我更有用。所以在某个时刻你
reduce all this stuff so that way you can manipulate this data so about you to be able to tell story and put this information where you want it. This is going to be your first step. Now you're using this giant object and then you're going to move on into using JSON objects instead of this giant object. Like, this is a monster. You shouldn't be doing this in production level code. And then we're going to move on to use APIs because this is how the natural progression
不得不辞掉你的日常工作，直接去 Vets Who Code。给我们讲讲那个故事。其实，我觉得我们还没有解释过 Vets Who Code。所以给我们讲讲整个故事。我觉得这很迷人。收到。这很有趣。就像，哦，假新闻。Vets Who Code 最棒的部分是它帮助了我的职业生涯。
of that, right? But you're- Yeah, very cool so like that's just how i'm always trying to push them to think of themselves in that concept of like yes try and walk us through like vets who called who code so you're a developer um at what point did you say um i want to um it probably was in your mind the whole time but at some point you had you said to yourself you know i'm more useful as sort of um like a conduit or or um you know someone who can really get other people off the ground and so at some point you
我不需要停止工作。哦，不错。是的，我在 CVS 担任软件工程师。我得到了我的梦想工作，因为我通过 Vets Who Code 所做的工作，以及构建像 ComicBook.com 这样的东西。我不知道你们是否足够了解我，因为我不怎么展示我的极客属性，但我是一个超级美国队长粉丝，我从 2007 年 7 月左右开始就是美国队长粉丝。所以我是一个巨大的美国队长粉丝，而且我……关于美国队长，这太荒谬、太尴尬了，
had to kind of you know quit your day job and go straight to vets who call kind of walk us actually i don't think we've always explained vets who code too so kind of walk you know, quit your day job and go straight to Vetsu Code. Kind of walk us, actually, I don't think we've explained Vetsu Code, too. So kind of walk us through that whole story. I think it's fascinating. Roger that. It's funny. It's like, oh, fake news. Like, the best part about Vetsu Code is that it has helped my professional career.
所以我不会那样做。这很棒，播客，因为我不了解你们，你们不会取笑我。我不想被盾牌击中什么的。所以，嗯，我们是现实生活中的朋友，但是的，你知道，我需要的东西，Vets Who Code 最棒的地方在于，我一直在工作，因为我一直都有工作。我不想建立一个我只是在构建东西并拿走它的组织。我想做非营利组织的未来。当谈到技术时，最大的……当我是一个……我的意思是，我不知道你能不能看出来，不，我是南方的少数族裔。所以，你知道，你有那些针对你的差异。我们认为人们在听，Jerome 是非裔美国人，只是因为
I've not had to stop working. Oh, nice. Yeah, I work at CVS as a software engineer. I work on, like like i got my dream job because of the work i've done with vetsu code and building things uh uh comicbook.com like i don't know if you guys probably know enough about me like that because i don't let my geek flag but i am the biggest captain america fan and i have been a Captain America fan since like at least July of 2007 so like I'm a huge Captain America fan and like I have how ridiculous embarrassing about Captain
你知道，听众可能不知道你在说什么。是的，你在说什么？所以你有那些差异。你有那些你必须克服的事情。你必须做的一件事是资源方面的不平等，对吧？所以当你 20 多岁，看到这个问题需要解决时，你如何解决它？当你不是亿万富翁或百万富翁时，你如何为巨大的建筑和物理基础设施筹集资金？你使用你周围的工具。我拥有的最好的工具是什么？
America so I'm not gonna get like that that's awesome podcast because I don't know y'all like that y'all don't make fun of me I don't want to get hit with a shield or anything so uh well we are irls but yeah so you know the things that i needed the best thing about that to code was and and simultaneously working because i've been employed the entire time was a i didn't want an organization where i was building something and taking it like i wanted to do the future of non-profits and when it came to technology uh the biggest when i was when i was a i mean i don't know if you can tell no that's i'm a minority in the south um so you know you have those disparities that come against you and we think people are listening jerome is african-american just because
互联网。所以这就是我们开始的方式。我们是第一批远程非营利组织之一。这在考虑非营利组织如何运作时有点奇怪，因为我们从营利性行业偷了这个想法。但人们说非营利组织在移动到这一点上仍然很慢，因为我想人类的状况仍然被训练成“哦，我需要一个物理场所来感觉我把钱给了真正存在的东西”。但我说，你知道，我们相对于物理地点的优势，当你想到一个花费 130 万美元来帮助 50 个人时，你根本无法比较。而我们可以用 5000 或 6000 美元做同样的事情。
you know people are listening might not know what you're talking about. Yeah, what are you talking about? So you have those disparities. You have those things you have to overcome. One of the things you have to do is like inequality when it comes to resources, right? So when you're 20-something and you see this problem that needs to be solved, how do you solve it like how do you raise up you know the money for a giant building and physical infrastructure and things like that when you know you're not your dad's not a billionaire or a millionaire right um you use the tools around you what was the best tool i had the
那么你是怎么开始的？在开始的时候，你是否注意到很多你的朋友，那些在军队服役期满的人，也遇到了和你一样的问题？所以你看到他们走在你的足迹上。这就是启发你的原因吗？嗯，启发我的是，有一个人因为自杀而去世了。因为他……你知道，困扰他并导致他创伤的事情之一，就是我所听到的同样的事情。
internet so like that's what we started that's how we started we were like the one of the first remote non-profits stole it which is kind of weird when you think about how non-profits work because we stole the idea from the for-profit industry but people are like non-profits are still slow to move to that because like i guess the human condition is still trained to oh i need some place physical to feel like oh i'm giving my money to something that's actually there but i'm like you know the advantages that we've had over physical locations you know you just can't compare when you know you're thinking of like a physical location that's spending 1.3 million dollars to you know literally help like maybe 50 people. And we can do the same thing using five, 6,000, right?
互联网，这就是我们开始的方式。我们是首批远程非营利组织之一，这在非营利组织运作方式上显得有些奇怪，因为我们是从营利性行业借鉴了这个想法。但人们觉得非营利组织在转型方面仍然很慢，因为人类的习惯似乎还是倾向于认为，我需要一个实体场所，才能感觉到我把钱捐给了真实存在的东西。但我认为，我们相比实体办公地点的优势是无法比拟的。你想想，一个实体机构花130万美元可能只能帮助50个人，而我们用五六千美元就能做到同样的事情，对吧？
So how did you get started? So at the beginning, did you just notice a lot of your friends, you know, who are, you know, finishing their term in the military were also having the same issues that you had had? And so you saw them kind of walking in your footsteps. Is that what sort of inspired it? Well, what inspired it was that there was a person who had died because he had took his own life. Because he was, you know, one of the things that was bothering him and was causing him trauma was the same thing that I was hearing,
那么你是怎么开始的呢？在最初阶段，你是否注意到很多刚结束服役的朋友也遇到了和你一样的问题？你看到他们走上了你的老路，这就是启发你的原因吗？嗯，启发我的是，有一个人因为自杀去世了。因为他当时困扰他并导致他产生创伤的事情，和我所听到的是同一件事。
that I heard when I came, you know, to be in the middle of the military. In regards to, you know, thank you for your service when I qualified. He was doing everything he could to retrain into the type of job that he had had while in the military which was a mechanic but the opportunity just wasn't there.
我刚来的时候听到的，你知道，身处军队之中。关于，你知道，感谢你的服役，当我获得资格时。他尽其所能去重新培训，想从事他在军队时做的那种工作，也就是机械师，但机会就是不存在。
Out of despair, this young man took his life and um i was like what can i do to help this family because the way that things were set up they the va wasn't going to help this family bury him so i started fundraising for this family using technology raised 10 grand in like 27 hours and we were able to help this young man help his family and you know help them set money aside for his young daughter so that's how you know we did it um then people were looking at me like all right what else are you gonna do and mind you i think people don't understand that i'm like 26 27 at this time i'm'm stupid. I'm not like, I'm not Mark Zuckerberg levels. Like people make me out as a genius.
出于绝望，这个年轻人结束了自己的生命，嗯，我当时想，我能做些什么来帮助这个家庭呢？因为当时的情况是，退伍军人事务部（VA）不会帮助这个家庭安葬他，所以我开始利用技术为这个家庭筹款，在27小时内筹集了1万美元，我们得以帮助这个年轻人，帮助他的家人，你知道，帮他们为他年幼的女儿存下了一笔钱，这就是我们所做的方式，嗯，然后人们看着我，就像是，好吧，你接下来还要做什么？请记住，我觉得人们不明白我当时大概26、27岁，我很蠢。我不是，我不是马克·扎克伯格那种水平。人们把我塑造成天才。
And I'm like, no, I wasn't there. I'm never there. I was never, I was never that guy. Like this is all accident. Uh, and I was like, Oh, what? Uh, I don't know what I'm going to do. Uh, so what am I going to do? And I was just thinking, I was like, well, one of the things that's the most impactful thing to me is gaining control and understanding of technology. So I want to be able to do more of that with other veterans, right? Teach veterans about, you know, help veterans get this skill set so that way they can do things and change the world moving forward. And so that's where that idea came from.
我说，不，我不是那样，我从来都不是。我从来，我从来都不是那种人。这纯属偶然。呃，我当时想，哦，什么？呃，我不知道我要做什么。呃，所以我该做什么？我只是在想，我觉得对我来说最有影响力的事情之一就是获得对技术的控制和理解。所以我希望能够和其他退伍军人一起做更多这样的事情，对吧？教退伍军人，你知道，帮助退伍军人获得这套技能，这样他们就可以做些事情，并在未来改变世界。这就是那个想法的由来。
Yeah, that makes sense. I'm a firm believer of this idea that productivity is actually the root cause for a lot of other things. In other words, it's very difficult to make somebody happy or to make somebody wealthy or to make somebody really anything directly. And often if you look at the people who win the lottery and then they- They're still miserable.
是的，这很有道理。我坚信生产力实际上是许多其他事情的根本原因。换句话说，很难直接让某人快乐、富有或真正成就任何事情。通常如果你看看那些中了彩票的人，然后他们——他们依然很痛苦。
Yeah, they're miserable. And then they also blow it all. I mean, you hear so many stories. It's almost like this schadenfreude. We like to sort of laugh or have a chuckle at that. But the reality is you can even just helicopter drop a bucket of what somebody wants and it just will not work. But productivity is that one thing that I think is the cornerstone for really everything else. Everything else is kind of
是的，他们很痛苦。而且他们还会把钱挥霍一空。我的意思是，你听过太多这样的故事了。这几乎就像是一种幸灾乐祸。我们喜欢嘲笑或对此轻笑。但现实是，你甚至可以直升机空投一桶别人想要的东西，但这根本行不通。但生产力是我认为真正一切事物的基石。其他一切都是围绕着它构建的。
built around that. And so when you take somebody who's in the military, who's part of that system, and now they're not in that system anymore, think that that that that seems like one of the biggest identity shifts that you could you could really do it's one of the biggest identity shifts in humanity right now yeah well you know people you want to know that they are worth something right people want to know that they contribute people you know from relationships to the job you know people want to know that on some level they're part of something bigger and they're contributing positively to things. They don't want to be the exact opposite. Most people don't.
所以当你带走一个在军队里的人，一个曾经是那个系统一部分的人，而现在他们不再处于那个系统中了，我认为这似乎是你所能做的最大的身份转变之一，这是目前人类社会中最大的身份转变之一。是的，嗯，你知道，人们希望知道他们是有价值的，对吧？人们希望知道他们有所贡献，你知道，从人际关系到工作，你知道，人们希望在某种程度上知道他们是更大事物的一部分，并且正在为事物做出积极的贡献。他们不想成为完全相反的人。大多数人都不想。
So when we were initially starting, we were thinking of it the old school way of doing things with like partners and stuff like that. But like I said, biggest caveat was the South. And I don't know if you guys understand about the South. We are like on average two to five years behind what like East Coast and West Coast is doing when it comes to tech. of tech so when like I had when when I was learning things from my New York colleagues I spent like six months in New York trying to bring down itself I was essentially speaking Greek to everybody like no one knew what I was talking about so I was having this problem in which I was involved in the community that was in 2008 and I'm in the future so like how do I help
所以当我们最初开始时，我们是以老派的方式思考问题，比如合伙人什么的。但就像我说的，最大的警告是南方。我不知道你们是否了解南方。在技术方面，我们平均比东海岸和西海岸落后两到五年。所以当我从纽约同事那里学习东西时，我在纽约待了大约六个月，试图把技术带回南方，我基本上是在对牛弹琴，没人知道我在说什么。所以我遇到了这个问题，我参与的社区是在2008年，而我身处未来，所以我该如何帮助
people regardless of the constraints of region and how do I help people start moving start without their constraints of their communities and you know what they are like they are nuggets are you know the thing about veterans is because the military they you know we shuffled all over the place. So a guy who, like me, may be from the South, but now he's in Ohio. Or a guy in California may now be in Detroit or in Mississippi or something because of their military journey. So how do I help people and not let things like region, community, location, any of that stuff, like government, none of that stuff get in the way. And it was like the internet, right?
人们，无论地域的限制如何，我该如何帮助人们开始行动，摆脱他们社区的限制，你知道他们是什么样的，他们是小金块，你知道关于退伍军人的事情是，因为军队，你知道，我们到处被调动。所以一个像我这样的人，可能来自南方，但现在他在俄亥俄州。或者一个在加州的人现在可能因为他们的军事旅程而在底特律或密西西比州等地。所以我该如何帮助人们，而不让地域、社区、地点、任何这类东西，比如政府，任何这类东西阻碍他们。就像互联网一样，对吧？
So the first thing we did was after doing the website was we started a Slack channel. Second thing we did was start a GitHub organization. And we just kept moving and moving on. Like, what do we need to do to start a nonprofit organization, a nonprofit remote company? What did WordPress do? What did Basecamp do? Those are our two biggest models that we use. We use Automatic and Basecamp because, as people people know Basecamp automatic they're two of the most
所以我们做的第一件事是在做完网站后，我们开了一个Slack频道。第二件事是建立了一个GitHub组织。我们就这样不断前进。比如，我们需要做什么来创办一个非营利组织，一个非营利性的远程公司？WordPress做了什么？Basecamp做了什么？那是我们使用的两个最大的模型。我们使用Automatic和Basecamp，因为正如人们所知，Basecamp和Automatic是市场上最成功的两家80%到100%远程办公的公司，对吧？所以这是我非常强烈想要效仿的东西。我不，你知道，如果DHH可以创造Ruby on Rails，并且，你知道，创造出统治编程界近十年的东西。而且是在他位于德国或瑞士的地下室和家中，然后在业余时间成为一名一级方程式赛车手。我相信我一定能帮助退伍军人提升他们在编程方面的热情和技能，对吧？当然，我们最初进入Ruby on Rails有一个自然的进展，因为我们当时想，嘿，Ruby on Rails已经非常适合远程工作了。但正在发生的事情，特别是在美国市场，是因为代码学校也在做Ruby on Rails，而且他们，你知道，代码学校更资本主义。所以他们只是，你知道，在疯狂地输出
successful like 80 to 100 percent remote companies on the market right so that's something that I really strongly wanted to emulate I do not you know if you, DHH can create Ruby on Rails and, you know, create something that ruled programming for, you know, darn near a decade. And from his basement and from his home in Germany or Switzerland and then become like a Formula One driver in his spare time. I'm sure I can help veterans get their passion and skill up in programming, right? And, of course, it had a natural progression of us initially going into Ruby on Rails because we were like, hey, Ruby on Rails already was very remote work friendly. But the thing that was happening, particularly in the American markets, was that because co-schools were doing Ruby on Rails as well, and they, you know, code schools were more capitalistic. So they were just, you know, jamming out
这些，坦率地说，水平不高的Ruby开发者。他们使市场饱和，以至于人们不再雇佣入门级的Ruby on Rails开发人员，这实际上帮助我们发现了，你知道，我们正在观察事物。Node.js当时就像Drake的新专辑一样刚刚发布，我正在观察，尽管我当时是一名专业的Rails程序员，当我获得合同时，它是Rails，我获得了合同，人们问我更多关于JavaScript的问题，而不是Ruby on Rails的问题，因为React正在兴起，人们喜欢在Rails中使用React。所以我当时想，好吧，即使在这些Ruby on Rails的工作中，我也越来越多地被问到关于React和JavaScript的问题，而不是实际使用Ruby或Rails。他们甚至不在乎那些东西。就像，这里面有问题，所以我去找我的团队，我说，嘿，伙计们，我们要放弃整个Ruby领域了，对于那些使用Windows机器的人来说，这太难教了，呃，我们要么得让他们双启动，要么这就是一场噩梦，对吧？而且你知道，我们太忙于教授框架，这增加了大约六周的额外时间。
these, quite frankly, subpar Rubyists. And they were saturating the market to the point where people were not hiring entry level Ruby on Rails developers, which helped us actually find, you know, we were looking at things. No, JS had just dropped like
就像，你知道，你知道，我们当时在做18到20周的课程，因为，你知道，我们必须教授框架以及编程基础，因为，你知道，Ruby on Rails是魔法。所以你真的不能，你知道，什么是计算机编程基础。然后，你知道，当涉及到架构和类似的设计架构时，然后是Ruby on Rails，Ruby on Rails有很多东西为你准备好了，所以你真的不需要关心，是的，我的意思是他们有所有的脚手架，他们设置了数据库插件，我的意思是，这太棒了，但它，呃，一次要学的东西太多了。不仅如此，它还会阻碍你。就像我刚开始的时候，那是Ruby on Rails、Bootstrap、Angular的大潮，对吧？他们为你做了很多繁重的工作
a Drake album by this time and I was looking at how even though I was a professional Rails programmer at the time when I was getting contracts it was Rails and I was getting contracts and people were asking me more JavaScript
所以你可以做出东西来。我们注意到的是，正因为如此，你失去了很多从长远来看会让你变得更好的小东西，比如它更多的是关于生产力，让你能够快速做事情来向雇主展示，这样他们就会给你一个机会去获得一份工作，而不是花时间确保你掌握了基础知识，并且你是干净、利落且能够解决问题的，所以这就是为什么我们教MERN栈和JAM栈，但这只是课程的最后六周，我们全程重点关注JavaScript。
questions and Ruby on Rails questions because React was coming in and people liked using React with Rails. So I was like, well, I'm getting more and more questions even on these Ruby on Rails jobs about React and JavaScript than actually using Ruby or Rails. They don't even care about that stuff. Like, there's something here so i went to my team and i was like hey yo guys we're just gonna we're just gonna drop the whole ruby area it's too it's too hard to teach to people who are on windows machines uh we either got to get them to dual booted or it's just a nightmare right and you know it's just I get we get so busy having to teach the framework that it adds like six extra weeks.
我们教MERN的原因是因为我们能够重点关注JavaScript。同样，我们不做任何CSS框架，没有那些东西，因为我不是那种追求纯粹主义的人。我喜欢CSS框架。它们让工作变得容易多了。只是在这里，你需要专注于，就像，这是实战演练，对吧？这是拳击馆。你不能在这里走捷径，因为如果你在这里走捷径。你在擂台上就会暴露，对吧？
Like, you know, you know, we were doing 18, 20 week courses because, you know, we had to teach framework as well as programming fundamentals because, you know, Ruby on Rails is magic. So you really can't, you know, it's what computer programming fundamentals are. And then, you know, when it comes to architecture and things like that design architecture then there's ruby on rails ruby on rails has a lot of stuff for you so you don't really have to care about yeah i mean they have all the scaffolding and they set up yeah plugins for the databases i mean it's it's awesome but it's uh it's a lot to learn at once. Not only that, it hinders you. Like when I was first starting, it was the big Ruby on Rails bootstrap Angular drive, right? And they did a lot of the heavy lifting for you
是的，这很有道理。所以这就是我的方法。那么，比如，你知道，回到现在人们对Vets Who Code有了一定的了解，所以这是你提供的服务，它是线上的，还是人们亲自来到教室？我们正在纳什维尔进行我们的第一次线下课程，今年这很可怕，但主要是因为这是我一直不想做的事情。Comcast给了我1万美元让我做这件事，我当时想，哦，好吧，我想我现在得把它建立起来了，所以现在我正在做所有这些工作，以确保纳什维尔有他们自己的BWC课程，所有这些都在进行中，这样如果我，比如，如果我搬家了，我会想，好吧，呃，你们，我已经完成了我在社区的善举，嗯
so you can make things. And what we noticed was that because of that, you were losing a lot of the little things that would make you in the long run like it was about more about productivity and getting you able to quickly do things to showcase to an employer so they take a chance to get a job versus taking the time and making sure you had fundamentals down and you were clean crisp and able to solve problems so that's one that like we teach mernstack and jamstack but that's like the last like six of the cohort, and we focus heavily on JavaScript the whole time.
所以是的，所以我们正在这样做，但我们的大部分课程都是在线的，我们这样做是因为，你知道，它帮助我们找到那种部队和人员，这更多是因为我们不想限制那些愿意做这项工作的人，因为地点，一个很好的例子是，我们有一个叫Andrew的学生，一个校友，Andrew James。他，当我第一次见到他时，我以为他是个喷子。他联系他以获取更多关于Vets Who Code的信息。而且，你知道，他需要有人帮助指导他，让他实现他的目标。他在芬兰。我当时想，不，你是ISIS。让我屏蔽你。所以他在Twitter上联系我，因为他先在LinkedIn上联系我。
The reason why we teach Mern is because we're able to focus heavily on JavaScript. In the same way, we don't do any CSS frameworks, none of that stuff, because I'm not so stickler for being a purist. I love CSS frameworks. They make the job so much easier. It's just that in here, you need to focus on, like, this is sparring, right? This is the boxing gym. You can't cut corners in here because you cut corners in here. You're going to get exposed in the ring, right?
我当时想，屏蔽。然后他在Twitter上联系我，说，嘿，不，我是个真人。所以就像，你在撒谎。好吧，让我们上Google。让我们上聊天软件。他只是在问你关于飞机的问题，诸如此类的。是的。所以我们在Google视频聊天上，我当时想，好吧，你是个真人，你不是想，像，嗯，你
Yeah, that makes sense. So that's how I approach it. What about, like, you know you know getting back to so now people kind of have an understanding of Vets Who Code so it's this service that you provide is it online or do people physically come to a classroom we are having our first IRL
不问任何秘密，因为我没有秘密，但他证明了他有一个非常独特的故事，他是一名在芬兰的海外合同工，他生命中的挚爱，待了几年，快要娶她了，但他的家人，他的妈妈、爸爸年纪大了，他们生病了，他想回家，但他意识到当他回到美国时，他并没有真正具备可以快速转移的技能来找到工作
cohort in Nashville it's terrifying this year but most because like it's the one thing I didn't want to do ever Comcast gave me 10 grand to do it I was like oh okay I guess I'm setting this up now so it's like now I'm doing all this work to make sure that Nashville has their own BWC cohort like all this going on like so that way if I like oh if I move I'm like okay uh you guys are i've done my you know good deed in community um
所以这就是Vets Who Code介入的地方，我们，当他在海外，在我看来是在荒郊野外，对吧？芬兰可能很棒。但对我来说，当我听到这个名字时，它听起来很冷。是的，我的意思是，如果你在芬兰的最北端，你会过得很冷。
so yeah so we're doing that but most of our classes are online and we do that because you know it helps us find the type of troops and people it's more so like we don't want to confine people are willing to do the work because locale um one great example of that is we have a student named Andrew, an alumni, Andrew James. And he, when he first met me, I thought he was a troll. He reached out to him to get more information about Vetsu Code. And, you know, he needed someone to help mentor him, get him on his goals. And he was in Finland. And I was like, no, you're ISIS. Let me block you. So he hit me up on Twitter because he first hit me up on LinkedIn.
是的。他告诉我们，就像，你知道，人们把他们的，就像，那里太冷了，人们只是，他们经历，就像，一种轻微的抑郁。但他们也，就像，把婴儿放在外面，在海岸边，这样他们可以更快地适应它。是的，我知道。对。当我，我的父母，
I was like, block. Then he hit me up on Twitter like, hey, no, I'm a real person. So it's like, you're lying. All right, let's get on to Google. Let's get on the chat. He was just asking you questions about aircraft you saw, things like that. Yeah. So we're on this google uh video chat and i'm like okay you're a real person you are you you're not trying to like like well you
我的父母告诉我，在，在，嗯，在意大利，我父母来自那里，他们会，嗯，他们会把婴儿扔进水里，让他们适应游泳。
don't ask for no secrets because i don't have them but he turned out like he had a very unique story he was he got a contract worker overseas in finland the love of his life, stayed years, about to marry her but his family his mom, dad were older they were sick, he wanted to come back home but he realized he didn't really have a quickly transferable skill to get a job when he came back to America
我的意思是，当然他们会去接住他们，但就像，你才一岁半、两岁。他们只是把他们扔进水里。就像，哟，这在美国是虐待，这是虐待儿童，是的，是的，我的意思是如果我那样做，你知道在这里，他们会让我面壁思过，你知道，好吧，我知道，别，别，别那样做，你的意大利亲戚，伙计
so this is about Sukhoi comes in and we're, while he's overseas in the middle of nowhere to me, right? Finland is probably awesome. But to me, it just sounds cold when I say the name. Yeah, I mean, if you're at the top of Finland, you're having a chilly time.
所以我们正在经历这个过程，在他还在那里的时候训练他。然后他开始为他的另一半办理签证工作。他们最终来到了这里。他最终在这里做了更多的培训。他不得不花几次时间，就像，在经历那个过程的同时做一些学徒工作。最终在达拉斯的Verizon获得了他的第一份高级软件工程师工作。所以我们当时想，天哪。就像，哟，你的第一份工作，你就是达拉斯Verizon的高级软件工程师。所以我们当时想，天哪。就像，哟，你的第一份工作，你就是高级？
Yeah. He was telling us, like, you know, people put their, like, it's so cold that people just, they go through, like, a mini depression. But they also, like, put the babies out there during the coast so they can get acclimated to it quicker. Yes, I know. Right. When I was like, my parents,
我说，那不是我在科技行业的第一份工作。这让我超级开心，因为我当时想，哟，我的学员们正在获得比我第一份工作大得多、酷得多的工作。告诉我们关于那个。我的意思是，假设，你知道，所以显然会有一些雇主，你出现时，你说，
my parents told me that in, in, um, in Italy where, where my parents are from, they would, um, they would throw babies in the water to get them acclimated to swimming.
高中学历，在军队的时间，Vets Who Code，我有技能，他们只是说回家，对吧？会有其他人。那是误解……我认为那被误解了。不仅仅是，嘿，他们只是VWC的学员。我们专注于确保他们有东西来展示他们的工作。
I mean, of course they'd go catch them, but it's like, you'd be like one and a half, two years old. They just throw it in the water. Like, yo yo this is abuse in america this is child abuse yeah yeah i mean if i did that you know here they'd have me facing a wall you know well i know i don't don't don't do your italian relatives dude
比如，哦，他们的GitHub很充实。他们的CodePen很充实。他们能够聪明地回答问题。我们正在培训他们的编程基础。我们的课程中有一部分他们只是专注于计算机科学本身，对吧？然后他们从第一周一直构建到第16周。而且他们，你知道，从一开始，我们就专注于一种语言，这样我们就可以更多地关注计算机科学中的基础知识和范式，而不是从一种语言跳到另一种语言
so like we were going through this process of training him while there. And then he started doing the visa work for his significant other. And they ended up coming here. He ended up doing more training while here. He had to spend a few times, like, doing some apprenticeship stuff while going through that process. Ended up getting his first job as a senior software engineer in Dallas at Verizon. So we were like, holy crap. Like, yo, your first job and you're a senior software engineer in Dallas at Verizon. So we were like, holy crap. Like, yo, your first job and you're a senior?
从一个框架跳到另一个框架，这样他们就能变得更好，因为编程，就像，你知道，我认为，呃，招聘经理，我的意思是Facebook就是一个很好的例子，招聘经理正在变得更好，变得更聪明，他们意识到学位什么都不代表。Facebook、苹果、微软，他们都取消了学位，取消了在那里获得工作的强制性学位要求。所以他们正在学习他们所做的事情，虽然达到那个水平需要独特的资质，但这只是在那个水平，对吧？那是组织里的三巨头。那是雷神、美国队长，是的，不，是的，显然不是，那里有，嗯，我不是说整个公司都这样做，但我说，你知道，有
I'm like, that was not my first job in tech. And that made me super happy because I was like, yo, my troops are getting jobs that are way bigger and cooler than my first job out the gate. Tell us about that. I mean, let's say, you know, so obviously there's going to be some employers where you show up, you say,
会有人在那里，某个有这种偏见的招聘经理，对吧？所以从与许多想要进行这种转换的人交谈中，我注意到的一件事是，如果你把它记在心里，它，你可以让它，它会感觉比实际更真实，对吧？所以我认为很大程度上是关于，你知道，面试表现好，而且还要有那种自信，你知道，虽然行业正在经历这种转型，因为正如你所说，你知道，不超过五年前，他们还把学位作为要求。现在他们不这样了。我们如何给人们自信？
high school degree, time in the military, FET2 code, I have the skills, and they just say go home, right? There's going to be other people. That's the mis... I think that's being misconstrued. It's not just, hey, they're just the VWC troops. We focus on making sure they have the things to showcase their work.
我想你已经暗示了这一点，你知道，建立一个非常扎实的GitHub作品集之类的东西。但你教什么？也许这是最后一课之类的。但你在最后教什么？我说这是你如何走进面试并带着工作离开，好吧，这就是重点，我们不在最后教那个，他在开始时说，因为你知道，这回到了纪律等于自由，对吧？你知道，如果你焦虑，如果你不觉得你属于这里，如果你不努力，你就会失败。这就是秘密，对吧？VWC，我们的Slack频道，充满了行业专家。到处都有，我们有来自Google Cloud的工程经理，
Like, oh, their GitHubs are fleshed out. Their code pins are fleshed out. They're able to answer the questions intelligently. We are training them in programming fundamentals. There's a section of our cohort where they're just focusing on computer science by itself, right? And then they're building from week one all the way to week 16. And they, you know, from the gate, we focus on one language so we can focus more on fundamentals and paradigms that are in computer science versus jumping from language and language
来自Facebook、微软的人，在那里帮助你。我们的课程是围绕构建MERN栈和JAM栈中的生产级产品所需的知识设计的，这些公司会欣赏这些产品。我们让你编写生产级代码。我们经历那个过程。所以对于人们，我一直说，去做工作。自信来自于做工作。我喜欢，因为我是格斗运动
framework to framework so that way they can get better and because program like you know i think uh hiring managers i mean facebook is one of them as a great example hiring managers are getting better and getting smarter and they're realizing the degree doesn't mean anything facebook apple microsoft they've all dropped the degree, the mandatory degree aspect of getting a job there. So they're learning that the things they do, like while it takes a unique level of aptitude to get to the level, that's just at that level, right? Those are the big three in the organization. That's the Thor captain america yeah no yeah obviously there's not there there's um i'm not saying that that companies as a whole do that but i'm saying you know there's
迷，我总是回到格斗运动，对吧？你知道，迈克·泰森之所以自信，不是因为，你知道，他肌肉发达，他自信是因为他有多年击倒对手的经验，所以他知道他能做到，就像你现在看到的，你是早期UFC的忠实粉丝吗，比如UFC 1？是的，哦，是的，这令人难以置信，我的意思是，我很久没看那个了，但我记得看过其中的一些，你知道，没有重量级，呃，他们不戴护齿，基本上没有地方可以肘击后脑勺，那时候简直太疯狂了，而且，呃，是的，迈克·泰森太疯狂了，我只是不知道我们是否还能回到那些日子，那些日子简直太狂野了。哦，是的。
going to be someone out there some hiring manager out there who has that bias right and so one of the things i've noticed from just talking to a lot of people who want to sort of make this switch is that is that it's one of these things if you get it in your head it you can kind of make it it can kind of feel more real than it really is right and so I think a lot of it is about you know interviewing well and also but having sort of that confidence you know while the industry is kind of going through this transition because as you said you know it wasn't more than maybe five years ago they were having degrees as a requirement. Now they're not. How do we sort of give people the confidence?
嗯，那很好。但回到那个类比，当你想到Gracie家族时，他们有信心去竞争，无论如何，知道没有，你知道，有，没有保护，因为字面上几代人的努力，所以当涉及到，我，我完全相信自信是，你知道，了解你的东西的副产品，对吧？这就是那个类比的由来，就像如果你每天都在推送代码，你每天都在写代码，你每天都在学习，如果你每天至少花两到四个小时沉迷于此，我试着告诉他们，你知道吗，至少投入25分钟。就像每天，25分钟是编程的一小笔代价，你，
I think you kind of hinted at this with, you know, building a really solid GitHub portfolio and things like that. But what do you sort of teach? Maybe it's the last lesson or something like that. But what do you teach at the end? It's I say this is how you walk into an interview and walk away with a job well see that's the thing we don't teach that at the end he said at the beginning because you know it goes back to discipline equals freedom right you know if you're anxious if you don't feel like you're you belong if you're you're going to fail if you don't do the work. And that's the secret, right? VWC, our Slack channel, is filled with people who are experts in the industry. Everywhere we have everyone from engineering managers at Google Cloud in there,
我的意思是，特别是在这个时代，当涉及到JavaScript时，它是，你知道，这是JavaScript教育和工具的黄金时代。就像80%最好的东西都是免费的。其他上层的东西，那不是免费的，我的意思是，他们总是在做折扣码和促销，比如，你知道，而且，你知道，你有Syntax，所以你可以在开车时听关于JavaScript和行业的事情，当涉及到JavaScript时，你有像你们这样的人做Programming Throwdown，获得，你知道，点滴知识，就像我们处于编程的黄金时代，人们只是字面上，你知道，到处寻找，就像给你工具，你知道，就像
people from Facebook, Microsoft, there to help you. And our curriculum is designed around what it requires to build a production-level product in MernStack and Jamstack that these companies would be appreciative of. And we put you on production-level code. We go through that. So with people, I've always said, do the work. The confidence comes from doing the work. I like, because i'm a combat sport
几乎亲手递给你，当我开始的时候，那不是，你知道，仍然像狂野西部一样，发生着最新的事情，嗯，你知道，所以我说，你知道，没有借口，只是去做工作，愿意去做工作，承受挫折，我说这是一种技能，所以每一天都是周一，有些周一很糟糕，所以你必须明白这一点，你必须能够，你知道，一步一个脚印。我明白你的目标是仅仅比昨天好1%，而不是尝试，就像你不会每天晚上都想出一个程序，但1%是不同的。它每次都会改变。
fan i always go back to combat sports right you know mike tyson wasn't confident because you know he was buff he was confident because he had years and years of experience of knocking people out so he knew that he could do it like you see now were you a big fan of early ufc like ufc one yeah oh yeah it's unbelievable i mean i it's been a long time since i saw that but i remember watching some of those and you know there were no weight classes uh they didn't wear mouth guards there's basically no where to get elbow to the back of the head it's just insane back then and uh yeah mike tyson was insane it's just i don't know if we'll ever get back to like those, those days were just wild. Oh yeah.
看看那1%。1%每天都在递增地变化。今天的1%将能够真正记住HTML，如何把HTML放在那里。就像，然后明天，你的1%是你将知道带有HTML的命令和图像。就像，你甚至不会去想它。之后的1%，不仅你将能够做所有这些，你还将知道所有你需要为Web可访问性目的而改变的事情。
Well, that's good. But going back to that analogy, when you think about the Gracies, they had the confidence to compete with that regardless, knowing that there was no, you know, there's, there was no protections because of literally generations of putting in the work so when it comes i i have a i fully believe that confidence is a byproduct of you know knowing knowing your stuff right so that's where that whole analogy comes from like if you're pushing code every day you're writing code every day you're studying you're if you are obsessing about this at least two to four hours a day, I try to tell them like, you know what, at least dedicate 25 minutes to this. Like every day, 25 minutes is a small price to pay for programming that you,
之后的1%不仅能够做到这一点，你还将能够像你一样轻松地搭建样式和CSS，所以1%会犯罪性地改变，如果你在做工作，这就是自信的来源，这就是我能够，你知道，回答问题并获得像面试所需的技能，以及，你知道，像VWC，我们不只是把它留给他们，我们把他们和一个导师联系起来。就像在第一阶段之后，明天对他们来说就结束了，我们开始根据他们的长处和短处为他们分配导师，对吧？所以这是一件事。就像，你知道，Twitter是寻找导师的金矿。
I mean, especially like in this current era, when it comes to JavaScript in general, it's, you know, this is the golden era of JavaScript education and tools. Like 80% of the best stuff out there is free. other upper echelon of that stuff and that isn't free I mean you they're always doing discount codes and sales on like, you know, and you know You have syntax so you can listen about JavaScript and things about the industry while driving when it comes to JavaScript You have guys like you guys doing programming throwdown getting you know tidbits like we're in the golden era of programming where people are just literally like you know looking all over the place and like to give you the tools you know like
能够阅读人们的旅程，看看他们10年后会在哪里，就像在秘密中，嗯，Sarah Drasner，她讲了这个故事，关于这个，呃，艺术老师，这个陶艺老师告诉教室里的两组人，有，嗯，你会以两种方式变得伟大，谁做一组，你必须至少做50个罐子，为了得到A，另一组，你必须给我一个完美的罐子，但问题是，那些做50个罐子的人，最终比那些一直在理论化，只是试图得到一个完美罐子的人，做出了更高质量的工作，所以你有同样水平的代码，对吧？你必须不断构建，不断出现，不断做那些可能不是你最好作品的事情，以达到你最好的作品，对吧？
hand deliver them to you almost when i started that wasn't you know still like kind of like the wild west kind of latest stuff going on well you know so i'm like you know there's no excuse like just do the work be willing to do the work take the bruises i said it's a skill so every day is a monday and some mondays suck so you have to understand that and you have to be able to you know put one foot forward in front the other. I understand your goal is to get simply 1% better versus trying, like you're not going to come up with a program every night, but 1% is different. It's going to change every time.
是的，有这个，我不记得是谁说的，但想法是，所以我认为他们是从艺术的角度谈论它的。他们说如果你对艺术有很好的眼光，你知道，你只是天生的，那么你画的第一件事在你看来会比那些没有好眼光的人看起来糟糕得多，实际上Patrick和我谈论过这个，我的意思是，我根本没有音乐天赋，我得到了这个应用程序，你可以，呃，用手指在iPad上做出不同的旋律，它们听起来都很棒，而且，而且，我想把它发给所有的朋友，我意识到，等一下，我一点天赋都没有，它只是看起来很棒，听起来很棒，因为我一点天赋都没有，对吧？反之亦然，那些拥有非常非常好的
Look at it at that 1%. 1% changes incrementally from day to day. 1% today is going to be able to actually remember HTML, how to put HTML on there. Like, then tomorrow, your 1% is you're going to know the command and image with HTML on there. Like, you're not even going to think about it. 1% after that, it's not only you're going to be able to do all that, you're also going to know all the things you need to change for web accessibility purposes.
眼光，对软件工程有热情的人，他们写的第一件事可能会让他们非常非常失望，但这就是他们必须意识到那种悖论存在的地方，他们必须坚持下去，变得越来越好，是的，就像，你知道，那是秘密，就像，我的意思是自信是，你知道自信是一种技能，就像一切，当涉及到我们经历的很多事情时，它们都是技能，你获得它们的唯一方法就是构建它们。就像面试也是一种技能。你必须练习面试。这是我们在VWC做的事情之一。我们让他们练习面试。
The 1% after that is not only going to be able to do that, you're going to be able to scaffold a style and see with as easy as you can So 1% changes that criminally if you're doing the work and that's where the confidence comes from And that's what I'm being able to you know Answer the questions and get the skills like you need for the interviews as well as you know like VWC We don't leave it just up to them and we connect them with a mentor. Like after block one, which ends tomorrow for them, we start assigning them mentors based upon their strengths and weaknesses, right? So that's one thing. Like, you know, Twitter is like a goldmine for being able to find mentors.
我们做模拟面试。我们去，当我与人们进行一对一交流时，我说，嘿，我想进行一些模拟面试演练。就像那些仍在寻找工作过程中，或者他们正在寻找新工作的人。就像，嘿，好吧，把你的简历发给我。让我们看看发生了什么。
Being able to read people's journeys and see where they were 10 years from now like in the secret um sarah drasner she tells his story about how uh this uh art teacher this pottery teacher told two groups in the classroom that there's um that you'd be great at two ways whoever does one group can you have to do at least 50 pots um in order to get an a in other groups you have to give me a perfect pot but the problem was the ones who did the perfect who did the 50 pots turned out higher quality work than the people who were theorizing the whole time and just trying to get the one perfect pie so you have the same level code right you have to constantly build constantly show up constantly do things that you may not may not be your best work to get to your best work, right?
让我们，好吧，让我看看你的LinkedIn之类的东西，这就是整个导师制发挥作用的地方，就像有走过那条路的人帮助你，但你仍然必须做工作，对吧？这就是你成长和变得更好的方式，对吧？所以我只是说，我们在BWC有一个说法，叫技能买单。这就是我看待它的方式。就像你做的事情。Vets Who Code和编码在某种程度上非常相似，你投入多少，得到多少。不是反过来的。你知道，你不能出现几次，然后期望有人给你6万美元、7万美元、8万美元，不，你知道你，你愿意投入多少工作，你就会
Yeah, there was this, I can't remember the gentleman who said this, but the idea was, so I think they talked about it in terms of art. They said if you have a really good eye for art, you know, you just are unnatural, then the first thing you draw is going to look so much worse to you than someone who doesn't have a good neck and actually patrick and i have talked about this i mean i'm i have no musical ability at all and i got this app where you could uh kind of just with your finger on the ipad kind of make different melodies and they all sound amazing to me and and i i wanted to send it to all my friends and i realized wait a minute i have zero talent it just looks amazing sounds amazing to me because i have zero talent right and the opposite is also true the people who are who have a really really good
得到多少，人们看我的轨迹，他们认为这就像，你知道，超速，就像很快，你必须明白，十多年来，或者我想说五年，因为我不算前五年，特别是在，你知道，当我在国土安全部时，那不是合法的编程，因为那只是数据库的东西。但我一直沉迷于此。所以当我不在工作时，如果我不在工作，不在寻找解决方案，
eye and have a good passion for software engineering the first thing they write might really really disappoint them but that's where they have to realize sort of that that paradox exists they have to kind of push through and get better and better yeah like you know that's a secret the secret of like i mean confidence is you know how confidence is a skill like everything when it comes down to a lot of things that we experience are skills and the only way you get them is you build them. Like even with interviewing is a skill. You have to practice interviewing. That's one of the things we do at VWC. We let them practice interviewing.
我在家寻找Vets Who Code的解决方案。我把事情按时间分块。我教授我在工作中使用的东西。我把我工作中使用的东西应用到我的非营利组织中。我使用我在工作中使用的相同工具。我发现我喜欢它。我从一家十亿美元的公司出来，教新手如何使用这些与十亿美元公司相同水平的工具，对吧？这就是那个，就像，那是秘方，就像，你知道，一件事如何支付并帮助另一件事，对吧？你知道，嗯，EWC的创始人，我们三个人都在非常酷的地方工作，我在CBS，不，Noel他在USAA，Andrew在USA Today。我们来，我们教人们东西
We do mock interviews. We go, when I have my one-on-ones with people, I'm like, hey, I want to go through some mock interview drills. Like those who are still looking in the process of getting a job or they're looking to get a new job. Like, hey, okay, send me your resume. Let's see what's going on.
我们知道它有效。这就是在这个水平上有效的东西。这就是我们要教你的东西。我们过去教一些别人正在做的事情，我们想，我永远不会碰Canvas。
Let's, all right, let me look at your LinkedInin and things like that like that's where the whole mentorship aspect comes in like having someone that's gone that way helps you but you still gotta do the work right and that's how you grow and how you get better right so i just like said we have a saying at BWC called skills pay the bills. And that's how I look at it. It's like what you do. Betsy Code and coding is very similar in the idea that you get out what you put in. It's not the other way around. You know, you can't show up a few times and then expect someone giving you a $60,000 seventy thousand eight eighty thousand no you know what you um what you're willing to put in the work is what you're going
我从来没有在生产水平上碰过Canvas。我不会教它。你知道，但我们教GraphQL，因为你猜怎么着？人们正在转向生产级代码中的GraphQL。我们教React，因为人们转向了那个。我们教Firebase，因为Firebase是一个很好的方式，你知道，使用数据库
to get out people look at my trajectory and they think it's like you know super speed and like fast and like you gotta understand like for over a decade or like i guess i like to say half a decade because i don't count the first, especially at, you know, when I was at the department of home security is like legitimate programming because it was just database stuff. But I've been obsessing over this. So when I'm not working, if I'm not at work working and looking up solutions,
而不需要真正做数据库的事情。而且它非常面向JavaScript。所以我们不使用MongoDB，我们使用Firebase，对吧？这只是一个更容易的方法。我们专注于JavaScript和ES6。我们专注于如何编写，把jQuery变成JavaScript。我们做一些事情，嘿，你必须在工作中做这个。就像，别，我的意思是，如果你进入一个有10、15年历史的代码库的工作，
I'm at home looking up solutions for that suit code. I'm time boxing things. I'm teaching the things that I use at work. I'm applying the things I use at work to my nonprofit. I'm taking the same tools that I use at work. I find I love it. I'm coming out of the out of a billion dollar company and teaching rookies how to use these exact same tools on the level of that a billion dollar company does right so that's where that whole like that's the secret sauce like you know where one thing pays and helps the other right you know um the founders of ewc we all three of us work at really cool places i'm at cbs uh noel he's at usaa uh andrew is at usa Today. We come and we teach people things
你将不得不把别人的JavaScript从别人的jQuery中写出来。它会被记录得很差。我们的董事会成员之一，Brian Holt，曾在Reddit和Netflix工作，我当时就在频道里，我说，嘿，有人有任何，像，真的很烂的CSS文件吗，我可以扔给学生，这样他们就可以专注于调试、清理并尝试在其中实现CSS和Flexbox？
and we know it works. This is what works at this level. This is what we're going to teach you. We used to teach some things that other people were doing and we're like, I'm never going to touch Canvas.
因为这就是你必须做的。你必须找到，会有一些非常旧的代码库，需要安装一些更现代的东西来实现新功能。你将不得不对抗那些代码风格和那些必须防御性编码的东西，这样你就可以，你知道，让东西工作，他说，哦，我想我可以找到一些我曾经在我的旧工作中原型设计过的烂东西，但是的，太棒了，找到那个，让我们去把它做了，这就是我工作的风格，我说，我，我们的课程和我们的理想来自现实世界的经验，对吧？所以就像，嘿，我曾经处于一种情况，你正在与17、18000行代码库CSS作斗争，你正在向其中添加CSS Grid和Flex
I've never touched Canvas on production level. I'm not going to teach it. You know, but we teach GraphQL because guess what? People are moving towards GraphQL on production level code. We teach React because people move towards that. We teach Firebase because Firebase works is a great way to, you know, use databases
但你正在与这边的18000行主CSS文件作斗争，所以你必须进行防御性编码，只是为了做你想做的工作，让它以你想要的方式显示出来
without actually having to do database stuff. And it's very JavaScript oriented. So instead of using MongoDB, we use Firebase, right? It's just an easier way to do it. We focus on JavaScript and ES6. We focus on how to write, turn jQuery into JavaScript. We do things that, hey, you will have to do this on the job. Like, don't, I mean, if you go into a job where there's like a 10, 15-year-old code base,
所以我试着把这些教训，就像当我经历一些给我带来痛苦的事情时，我想，如果这不能激发快乐，让我确保它能给别人带来快乐，这就是我的哲学，对吧？这很有道理，是的，就像，你知道，这是一个，你知道，Vets Who Code就像，你知道，面包屑，给那些我愿意做工作的人，对吧？所以，是的。关于那个，那是一个非常好的观点。所以，我想，你知道，在Vets Who Code的情况下，有些退伍军人非常热情。
you're going to be turning writing somebody's JavaScript out of somebody's jQuery. It's going to be poorly documented. One of our board members, Brian Holt, used to work at Reddit and Netflix, and I was just in-channel. I was like, hey, does anyone have any, like, really crappy CSS files that I can throw at the students so they can focus on debugging, cleaning up and trying to implement CSS for it and Flexbox into?
他们，你给了他们一个绝佳的机会，对吧？那么，有很多平民。有很多学生。有很多Vets Who Code不适合他们的人，嗯，什么，你知道，你会向他们推荐什么，作为，你知道，可以，你知道，它可以是Vets Who Code的一个很好的代理，给那些要么不是退伍军人，要么，你知道，他们，你想要尝试不同的东西，我看到这很难，因为我试着，我试着保持在我的车道上。所以，首先，就像，所有会来到我这里的东西
Because that's what you're going to have to do. You're going to have to find there's going to be some really old code base that needs something that's more modern installed into it for a new feature. And you're going to have to combat those code styles and things that have had a code defensively and things like that so you can you know make stuff work and he was like oh i think i can find some crappy thing that i was like prototyping once upon a time one of my old jobs but yes awesome find that let's go and do that that's the type of that's the style that i work on i'm like i we our lessons and our ideals come from real world experience right so it's like hey i have been in a situation where you are battling a 17 18 000 or 18 000 18 000 uh line of uh code base CSS and you're adding CSS grid and flex to it
因为这就是你必须要做的事情。你必须去寻找，因为总会有一些非常陈旧的代码库，需要安装更现代的东西来实现新功能。你必须去应对那些代码风格，以及那些防御性编写的代码等等，这样你才能让事情运转起来。他说，哦，我想我可以找到一些我在以前某份工作中原型设计时写的烂代码。我说，太棒了，找到它，我们去用它，这就是我工作的风格。我们的课程和理念都来自现实世界的经验，对吧？就像，嘿，我曾经处于那种你需要与一个1.7万或1.8万行CSS代码库作斗争，并且还要在其中添加CSS Grid和Flex布局的情况。
but you're fighting a 18,000 line main CSS file over here so you're having to write code defensively just to do the work that you want to do, make it show up the way you want it to make it show up
但你这边正在与一个1.8万行的主CSS文件作斗争，所以你必须进行防御性编程，仅仅是为了完成你想做的工作，让它以你想要的方式呈现出来。
so I try to put those lessons like when i experience something gives me pain i'm like let me if this does not spark joy let me make sure that it sparks joy with other people like that's my philosophy right that makes sense yeah like you know it's a you know investment code is like you know breadcrumbs to those where i'm willing to do the work right so yeah what about that's that's a, you know, a Vetsu code is like, you know, breadcrumbs to those where I'm willing to do the work. Right. So, yeah. What about, that's a really good point. So, I think, you know, in the case of Vetsu code, there are some veterans are very enthusiastic.
所以我尝试把这些经验总结出来，当我经历了一些痛苦的事情时，我会想，如果这不能带来快乐，那我就要确保它能给别人带来快乐，这就是我的哲学，对吧？这很有道理。你知道，Vets to Code就像是为那些我愿意投入工作的人留下的面包屑。没错。所以，这是一个很好的观点。那么，我认为在Vets to Code这个案例中，有些退伍军人非常热情。
They, and you give them an amazing opportunity, right? What about, there's a lot of civvies. There's a lot of people who are students. There's a lot of people who Vets to code isn't the right thing for them um what uh you know what would you recommend to them as something that you know can you know it could be sort of a good proxy for vets who code for people who either aren't veterans or you know they they um you want to try something different i see that's tough because i try like i try to stay in my lane. So, like, first and foremost, like, everything that's going to come to me
他们，你给了他们一个绝佳的机会，对吧？那么，还有很多平民呢？有很多学生，有很多不适合Vets to Code的人。你会向他们推荐什么，作为Vets to Code的替代方案，或者对于那些不是退伍军人，或者想尝试不同事物的人来说，有什么好的选择？这很难，因为我尽量专注于自己的领域。所以，首先，所有来到我这里的东西...
is going to come from the point of view of a veteran who learned how to code and is a JavaScript developer. So it's really hard for me to give, like, advice like that for if you don't come from that. I can give you the tips and things that the – I wouldn't say tips, but these are basically literally things that I see that here's something that if you focus on, you'll be successful in the resources that I recommend to everyone all the time. First thing I always recommend is pick something that you're passionate about. In the end, the languages don't matter as much as if you're passionate about solving that problem. I don't know if I've been a programmer if it wasn't for Vetsu Code. I tell
将从一名学会了编程并成为 JavaScript 开发人员的退伍军人的角度出发。所以，如果你不是这种背景，我很难给出那样的建议。我能给你的是一些技巧，或者说，我不会称之为技巧，但这些基本上就是我所看到的，如果你专注于这些，你就会成功，这也是我一直向大家推荐的资源。我首先推荐的第一件事是选择你热衷的事情。归根结底，语言并不重要，重要的是你是否热衷于解决那个问题。如果不是因为 Vets Who Code，我不知道自己是否会成为一名程序员。我一直告诉
people that all the time. If I wasn't trying to solve this problem, I don't know if I'd stay as motivated as I was. There was no one around motivating me to become a programmer. Like, I live in the South where programming is nowhere near the biggest industry. Like, in Nashville, it's getting there, especially with Amazon coming in and stuff like that. But where I was at when I was in Memphis, it wasn't something, particularly in minority communities, wasn't something that was being, like like shouted from the rooftops as an option right um so i have no idea like what would happen if i hadn't had something to work towards something for betterment when you're especially when you're with everybody who's around you that knows this or is um rooting you on is in new york or they're
人们这一点。如果我不是在试图解决这个问题，我不知道自己是否还能保持像当时那样的动力。我周围没有人激励我成为一名程序员。比如，我住在南方，那里编程远不是最大的行业。比如在纳什维尔，情况正在好转，尤其是随着亚马逊等公司的入驻。但在我以前住的孟菲斯，这并不是什么特别是在少数族裔社区里，并不是什么被像从屋顶上大声疾呼的选择。所以，如果我没有一个可以努力的目标，没有一个可以让自己变得更好的东西，我真的不知道会发生什么，尤其是当你周围认识这个领域或者支持你的人都在纽约或者他们
in san francisco like it's really weird to like i tell people my biggest supporters are all either rooting you on is in New York or they're in San Francisco. Like it's really weird to like, I tell people my biggest supporters are all either in New York or San Francisco. I don't understand how this little Southern boy ended up getting fans in New York and San Francisco. Like it's cool. Like mama,
在旧金山的时候，这真的很奇怪。我告诉人们，我最大的支持者要么在纽约，要么在旧金山。这真的很奇怪，我告诉人们，我最大的支持者要么在纽约，要么在旧金山。我不明白这个南方小男孩是怎么在纽约和旧金山拥有粉丝的。这很酷。妈妈，
I made it. It's a beauty of the internet, right? Yeah. So, but that's the biggest thing find something you're passionate about like you know i chose javascript because i truly believe it is what i like to call the working man's tool is something that is not you know the speed of it and the ideals of it when
我成功了。这就是互联网的美妙之处，对吧？是的。所以，这是最重要的事情，找到你热衷的事情。你知道，我选择 JavaScript 是因为我真心相信它是我所说的“劳动者的工具”，它不是那种，你知道，它的速度和它的理念，从
it was from when it was first created to now has made it really hard to be gated by universities because A, universities don't teach it, B, because it's more functional, the object-oriented. You really can't gate it with like a lot of CS fundamentals because it's functional programming. It's just as much creativity as it is logic. It's right there in every browser in the world, so you have direct access to it regardless of how crappy your computer is. You can have an old Windows box or the sleekest MacBook out there, and JavaScript is still going to work in the browser, right?
它最初被创造出来到现在，使得它很难被大学所垄断，因为第一，大学不教它；第二，因为它更偏向函数式而非面向对象。你真的很难用大量的计算机科学基础知识来限制它，因为它是函数式编程。它既需要逻辑，也需要创造力。它就在世界上每一个浏览器里，所以无论你的电脑有多烂，你都能直接使用它。你可以拥有一台老旧的 Windows 电脑，也可以拥有最轻薄的 MacBook，JavaScript 依然能在浏览器中运行，对吧？
So that's why I chose JavaScript. You know, it just made everything that I wanted to do with everyone and every tool easier. And, you know, we're in the after the Node.js boom, you know, or, you know, like I say, the Drake makes tape drop. And it just exploded everywhere with React, Ember, Angular, Vue.js, Node, Express, Next, Gatsby. We have the Jamstack, we have Mernstack, we have Meanstack, we have Mervstack. Yeah, I think the beauty of JavaScript is
这就是我选择 JavaScript 的原因。你知道，它让我想要做的每一件事和使用的每一个工具都变得更容易。而且，你知道，我们正处于 Node.js 热潮之后，或者，就像我说的，Drake 发布混音带之后。它随着 React、Ember、Angular、Vue.js、Node、Express、Next、Gatsby 到处爆发。我们有 Jamstack，有 Mernstack，有 Meanstack，有 Mervstack。是的，我认为 JavaScript 的美妙之处在于
it's so easy to show somebody you just get a VPS and you can just easily go to someone and say hey, go to this URL and check out my cool website. It's not, you know, go to the Play Store you have to sign up for this
向别人展示它太容易了，你只需要一个 VPS，就可以轻松地对别人说：“嘿，去这个网址看看我做的酷网站。”而不是，你知道，去应用商店，你必须注册这个
beta version of the app and then oh, I started it and it crashed. The deployment is something where you can immediately get some feedback. I think it's really important for people early on for them to show something to your mom and she says, wow, that's amazing. I can't believe you made that by yourself. I'm just trying to get that going. Like I said, the tools, you have CodePen, you have GitHub, you have Revolet.
应用的测试版，然后，“哦，我启动了，结果崩溃了。”部署是一个你可以立即获得反馈的过程。我认为对于初学者来说，向你的妈妈展示一些东西，然后她说：“哇，太棒了，真不敢相信这是你自己做的”，这非常重要。我只是想让它运转起来。就像我说的，工具方面，你有 CodePen，有 GitHub，有 Replit。
Like these three tools are changing the game of like CS education in general. And, you know, they are just, they make it so much easier. They make it easy to showcase what you're doing. So I recommend those three tools to anyone on top of Stack Overflow. Stack Overflow is getting better. I'm going to be intrigued to what happens with this new CEO shakeup that's going on. Because even I have been bitten by the inexperience bug of going to Stack Overflow and expecting people to love me and be happy. I don't know. There's something about Stack Overflow developers
这三个工具正在改变整个计算机科学教育的游戏规则。而且，你知道，它们让一切变得简单多了。它们让你很容易展示你在做什么。所以我向任何人推荐这三个工具，此外还有 Stack Overflow。Stack Overflow 正在变得更好。我对这次新任首席执行官的改组感到好奇。因为即使是我，也曾因为缺乏经验而在 Stack Overflow 上被“咬”过，当时我以为人们会喜欢我并感到高兴。我不知道。Stack Overflow 的开发者们有些地方
and them hating everybody. I guess I'm drinking enough coffee. Maybe drink coffee black. I'm like, nah, I'm cool with that. This is true of almost every online community. There's always just like a cabal of veterans who are, not to overload the term veterans, but a cabal of people who have been in that community forever. And they're usually yeah i mean hostile is not the right word just like dismissive you know stack overflow is one of those where
总是讨厌每个人。我想我喝了足够的咖啡。也许喝黑咖啡吧。我心想，不，我没问题。这几乎适用于每一个在线社区。总有一群老手，不是要滥用“老手”这个词，而是一群在这个社区待了很久的人。他们通常，是的，我的意思是“敌对”不是正确的词，只是比较轻视，你知道，Stack Overflow 就是那种
you could submit a question and someone will just like kill your question they say oh it's it's too much opinion it's kind of like it's kind of like nimby but for tech yeah it's like nimby for tech it's like not in my backyard oh it's awesome that you can if you want to learn this question but not over here go play somewhere else little ricky so like i think it's an artifact of this this this this wave we're seeing where just everything you do is part of some democratic vote it's like you can't even just tell someone happy birthday without you know uh seeing like how many votes did I get? You know, how many whatever it is, how many hearts did I get on Twitter? Right.
你可能会提交一个问题，然后有人会直接“扼杀”你的问题，他们说“哦，这太主观了”。这有点像“邻避效应”（NIMBY），但针对的是技术。是的，就像技术界的邻避效应，就像“别在我家后院”。哦，如果你想学习这个问题，那很好，但别在这里，去别处玩吧，小瑞奇。所以，我认为这是我们看到的这股浪潮的产物，你所做的一切都是某种民主投票的一部分。就像你甚至不能祝别人“生日快乐”，而不去看看“我得到了多少票？”你知道，无论是什么，我在 Twitter 上得到了多少颗心？没错。
And so as soon as you kind of put that on everything, I think you kind of create that atmosphere. Yeah, you create that dopamine hit. And so people are either afraid because they don't think they're smart enough to do it. So they avoid you altogether. Or you have these people who are always doing it because and they become the rock stars because they built that clout or credentials up right yeah but then that's also how you know when you do that the best idea usually doesn't doesn't always gravitate towards the top because it's more you've done it in a manner to where it's a popularity contest now versus, hey, let's try this thing.
所以一旦你把这种东西强加在一切事物上，我认为你就创造了那种氛围。是的，你创造了那种多巴胺刺激。所以人们要么因为觉得自己不够聪明而害怕，从而完全避开你；要么你就有那些总是这样做的人，他们因为建立了那种影响力或资历而成为了摇滚明星。是的，但当你这样做时，最好的想法通常不会自动浮现到顶端，因为它现在变成了一场人气竞赛，而不是“嘿，让我们试试这个”。
Yeah, so you're absolutely right. So the Vets Who Code, so it's a nonprofit. It's distributed throughout the whole country or even maybe the whole world. World, yeah. Yeah, there's veterans all over the world. Yeah. all over the world. Are you sort of, are you like hiring for teachers or people to help with the website or what's that situation?
是的，你说得完全正确。所以 Vets Who Code，它是一个非营利组织。它分布在全国甚至可能是全世界。全世界，是的。是的，全世界都有退伍军人。是的，全世界都有。你是在招聘老师，还是需要人帮忙维护网站，或者情况是怎样的？
If there's someone, let's say just graduating college and they say, you know, I really want to help out this organization any way I can, what sort of a way that they can contribute? All right. So the way we do this is, first of all, it's a pro bono.
如果有人，比如说刚大学毕业，他们说：“你知道，我真的很想尽我所能帮助这个组织”，他们可以通过什么方式做出贡献？好的，我们这样做的方式是，首先，它是公益性的。
Like I said, I don't make any money over it. They gave me money, and then I put the money right back into the community. Like that's how I do things. Or I put the money in new resources. And we're about to grab two new companies as sponsors, technology sponsors. Literally, that's what happens they like i they gave me the funds and i spent a bunch of money to make sure infrastructure and stuff's going to be taken care of like the next five years for everyone and then we're adding up two new
就像我说的，我从中赚不到一分钱。他们给了我钱，然后我把钱直接投入回社区。这就是我做事的方式。或者我把钱投入到新的资源中。我们即将迎来两家新的赞助商，技术赞助商。字面上就是这样，他们给了我资金，我花了一大笔钱来确保基础设施等在未来五年内都能得到妥善处理，然后我们正在增加两个新的
projects now because i was like oh we have funds for it there you go bam done um how i like what we do the troops work on the products because so that way they can get confidence and you know experience and build a production level code um i started doing that when i was seeing that hey everything that i was building when it came to vwc was helping me and i'm kind of at a level where everyone already knows that i'm involved with bwc like i can't hide it i can't go on an interview and people not know that i'm involved with bwc right they google me oh there's you tell me more about this and like oh hey how you doing like this is awkward uh this is a crazy first date you stalking me already okay um so like when i was like you know what maybe i should let other people drive and like focus on the board like focus on the
项目，因为我当时想：“哦，我们有资金了，就这样，搞定。”我们所做的是让学员们参与产品开发，这样他们就能获得信心，获得经验，并构建生产级别的代码。我开始这样做是因为我看到，我在 VWC 构建的一切都在帮助我，而且我现在处于一个大家都知道我参与了 VWC 的水平，我无法隐藏它。我不能去面试而不让人们知道我参与了 VWC，对吧？他们谷歌我，“哦，你跟我多说说这个”，然后“哦，嘿，你好吗”，这很尴尬，这是个疯狂的第一次约会，你已经在跟踪我了吗？好吧，所以当我当时想，你知道吗，也许我应该让其他人来主导，专注于董事会，专注于
combine board and make the issues and the tickets and do the mock-ups and then start then you know start forecasting more like when we two years ago started looking at you know i wanted to move into react with the trip with vwc's uh web app but i didn't want to add a complex back end and gas beat was just coming up and the rise of jam stack was just coming up and i was like this is what we should do and so i started putting the tickets and doing discovery for that and letting the troops drive that and within like i gave them a year to do it within three months they transferred the entire stack to um gatsby jamstack app right so and now what we're doing like we have this a new domain we just bought that's who dot codes right and we're going to turn that into a directory
看板，制定问题和工单，做模型，然后开始更多地进行预测。比如两年前，我们开始考虑，我想在 VWC 的 Web 应用中转向 React，但我不想增加一个复杂的后端，而 Gatsby 刚刚兴起，Jamstack 的浪潮也刚刚兴起，我就想这就是我们应该做的。于是我开始制定工单并进行探索，让学员们去推动它。在大约一年内，他们就在三个月内将整个技术栈迁移到了 Gatsby Jamstack 应用，对吧？现在我们正在做的是，我们买了一个新域名，vetswho.codes，我们要把它变成一个目录。
and what's going to happen with that is our new troops that are in our alpha project our alpha team right now they are going through learning right now that's going to be their project you're going to be building you know that's who dot codes which is going to be a directory for everybody that's in the Vetsu code community. And then the Bravo team, we've already got their next phase of the project, which is going to be focusing on the job board portion of vetsu.co, right? And then we have right now, we have like, I don't know if you guys ever heard of the book, Team of Teams? No, I haven't. Yeah. I'm going to add this to my list General McChrystal
将会发生的是，我们目前在 Alpha 项目中的新学员，我们的 Alpha 团队，他们正在学习，这将是他们的项目。你们将要构建 vetswho.codes，这将是一个 Vets Who Code 社区所有人的目录。然后是 Bravo 团队，我们已经有了他们项目的下一阶段，将专注于 vets.co 的招聘板块，对吧？现在我们有，我不知道你们有没有听说过《团队之团队》（Team of Teams）这本书？没有，我没听过。是的，我要把它加到我的清单里，麦克里斯特尔将军。
if you notice I read a lot of stuff from generals and stuff Iraq War I guess generals how they changed combat was really in a less violent way when you take
如果你注意到，我读了很多将军之类的书，伊拉克战争，我想是将军们如何以一种不那么暴力的方式改变了战斗，当你拿走
when you take away the violence it mimics a lot of agile and combat methodologies right so now we do a lot of things that are teams of teams right you know we have the leadership quote-unquote team which is the dumbest thing on earth because i'm like i tell you i'm the most unqualified leader here like i want to shoot breeze and drink beer the rest of you guys uh i don't want to be in charge why do i have to like what do i have to make roles like just stupid uh then uh but we have people basically the executive team and then executive team is a head of usually a head of their own team so we have the code pen team they handle all the code pen stuff um designs when we do things like special like you know we did a new year's uh
当你拿走暴力时，它模仿了很多敏捷和战斗方法论，对吧？所以现在我们做了很多“团队之团队”的事情。你知道，我们有所谓的领导团队，这是世界上最愚蠢的事情，因为我告诉你们，我是这里最不合格的领导者，我只想吹牛、喝啤酒，你们其他人，我不想负责，为什么我必须，我为什么要制定规则，太蠢了。但我们有执行团队，执行团队通常是他们自己团队的负责人。所以我们有 CodePen 团队，他们处理所有 CodePen 的事情，设计方面，当我们做一些特别的事情时，比如我们做了新年
disco ball drop and yeah yeah they handle stuff like that got a ton of likes everybody loved it they shared it code pen loved it everybody was happy we got pick pin of the day it was awesome right um they you know they even put me on weird things like you know there's such a thing as a white castle valentine's you mean like the burger white castle yeah castle does a valentine's day dinner it's like has a cult following did not know that's awesome i know ikea does one that's the one i've heard of ikea does a valentine's day dinner they put me on to something brand new and i was like okay so this is real this is like you know this is not like some this is an april fools early like what's going on so okay like so that's things they do we have the product team they focus on keeping the product um basically
迪斯科球掉落，是的，他们处理这类事情。获得了大量的点赞，每个人都很喜欢，他们分享了它，CodePen 很喜欢，每个人都很开心，我们获得了“今日精选”，太棒了。他们甚至让我参与一些奇怪的事情，比如你知道有“白色城堡情人节”吗？你是说像汉堡店白色城堡？是的，白色城堡有情人节晚餐，它有狂热的追随者。我不知道，太棒了。我知道宜家也有一个，这是我听说过的，宜家有情人节晚餐。他们让我接触了一些全新的东西，我当时想，好吧，所以这是真的，这不是什么愚人节玩笑，到底发生了什么？所以，好吧，这就是他们做的事情。我们有产品团队，他们专注于保持产品
the web app cleaning, cleaning it up, fixing it, coming up with ideas. The, I handle the mock-ups for that. Um, I do all my mock-ups in HTML, CSS, JavaScript, because like you can design in a browser now. So there's no need for me to like, you know, open up a Photoshop file ever. Um, so I like that's what they do uh then we have um we have mentorship team that they focus on and then within the mentorship team there are two mentorship teams one is for you know current students and one is for alumni so we have continuing education mentorship team headed up by daniel pritchett and then we have a um troop mentorship team headed up by Daniel Pritchett. And then we have a troop mentorship team headed up by Mark Locklear. And what Mark handles, he focuses on mentors who are strong in JavaScript to be able to assign them to troops who are learning JavaScript.
Web 应用的整洁，清理它，修复它，提出想法。我负责模型设计。我所有的模型都是用 HTML、CSS、JavaScript 做的，因为你现在可以在浏览器中设计。所以我根本不需要打开 Photoshop 文件。所以这就是他们做的。然后我们有导师团队，在导师团队中有两个导师团队，一个是针对当前学生的，一个是针对校友的。所以我们有由丹尼尔·普里切特领导的继续教育导师团队，然后我们有由马克·洛克利尔领导的学员导师团队。马克负责的是那些 JavaScript 基础扎实的导师，以便将他们分配给正在学习 JavaScript 的学员。
While Daniel, he focuses on troops who have jobs. And then he lets them go, know understand next steps that it's okay to learn other languages like i'm like dad in the organization like no we're gonna stick to javascript just because that's what we're here for but daniel's mom and he's like no baby you can go learn go you can go you can do don't listen to him you can do whatever you want what about like people you know you might have a lot of uh i do like people in the military are always traveling right but there are definitely some people who especially when you think about veterans have sort of settled down and i know that you know a few times we've talked about how
而丹尼尔，他专注于已经有工作的学员。他让他们去了解下一步，学习其他语言是可以的。我就像组织里的“严父”，不，我们要坚持使用 JavaScript，因为这就是我们在这里的原因。但丹尼尔就像“慈母”，他说，不，宝贝，你可以去学 Go，你可以做，别听他的，你想做什么就做什么。那关于那些，你知道，你可能会有很多，我确实喜欢，军人总是四处奔波，对吧？但肯定有一些人，特别是当你想到退伍军人时，已经安定下来了，我知道我们谈过几次，关于
you know all of the sort of programming energy seems to concentrate in a few places right um do you feel like that's going to change? Do you tell people to move to New York or San Francisco? What's your sort of feeling about that? How is that going to evolve? Oh, it's evolving now. It's super, like, there's another Drake analogy. What a time to be alive. Right.
你知道，所有的编程能量似乎都集中在几个地方，对吧？你觉得这会改变吗？你告诉人们搬到纽约或旧金山吗？你对此有什么感觉？这会如何演变？哦，它现在正在演变。这太，就像，这是另一个 Drake 的类比。多么美好的时代。没错。
Because it's already already already evolving. Like I said, everything's five years behind. And while now while New York and Silicon Valley is kind of getting cold on the coding buzz, you know, now the South and the Midwest are kind of like of like oh we want to be in on this because you know i like to say i'm a big combat fan i believe in the fighter analogy um and the best fighters live in boring places like albuquerque new mexico and stockton california make great mixed martial artists because there's nothing else yeah because there's nothing else to do there. You're either drinking or fighting. Same concept with programmers. Silicon Slopes or when you're going
因为它已经在演变了。就像我说的，一切都落后五年。虽然现在纽约和硅谷对编程热潮有点冷淡，但现在南方和中西部开始觉得“哦，我们想参与其中”，因为你知道，我喜欢说我是一个战斗迷，我相信战士类比，最好的战士住在像新墨西哥州阿尔伯克基和加利福尼亚州斯托克顿这样无聊的地方，他们成为了伟大的综合格斗选手，因为那里没别的事可做。是的，因为那里没别的事可做。你要么喝酒，要么打架。程序员也是同样的道理。Silicon Slopes 或者当你去
to Utah, Utah Pluralsight's there. Brian Holt is from there. You go further north, Ontario, Hamilton, where there's nowhere, nothing to do, West Boston's from there. So the more boring the place,
犹他州，犹他州有 Pluralsight。布莱恩·霍尔特就是那里的人。你往北走，安大略省，汉密尔顿，那里什么都没有，韦斯·波士顿就是那里的人。所以地方越无聊，
the better the JavaScript developers are. Like, that's what I'm just, I'm learning that, like, the less there is to do, the better the talent. And, like, that's what's coming down here. Like, you know, right, I've gotten two opportunities to speak
JavaScript 开发人员就越好。这就是我正在学习的，地方越没意思，人才就越好。这就是正在发生的事情。比如，我已经得到了两次在
at conferences with no CFP. They just like, yeah, we would love for you to come down. Well, okay, in Mississippi and Georgia. So I'm very happy to finally be able to speak in my backyard versus having to go either to New York or to California for speaking engagements. Although I do have one in Columbia, which is my first international speaking engagement.
会议上发言的机会，没有经过 CFP（征稿）。他们只是说，是的，我们很乐意让你过来。好吧，在密西西比州和佐治亚州。所以我很高兴终于能在自己的后院发言，而不必为了演讲去纽约或加利福尼亚。虽然我在哥伦比亚有一个，这是我的第一次国际演讲。
It's going to be great. Oh, I thought you meant the college at first. No, no. I'm talking the country. Like, you know, it's going to be insane. Yeah, I think it's, you know, and Patrick and I have talked about this before, but, you know, I think the whole remote work revolution,
那会很棒。哦，我起初以为你说的是那所大学。不，不。我说的是那个国家。那会很疯狂。是的，我认为，你知道，帕特里克和我之前谈过这个，但我认为整个远程工作革命，
you know, we're just kind remote work revolution, you know, we're just kind of waiting for that to drop, you know, it's almost there because, you know, in the end, you know, we are one of the few jobs where you don't need to be in the room. And because we require, you know, you get rid of the book deep work and things like that, like how Gil Gates takes all the books he's going to read in the year and, you know,
我们只是在等待它的到来，它快到了，因为归根结底，我们是少数不需要在同一个房间工作的职业之一。因为我们需要，你知道，你摆脱了《深度工作》那本书和类似的东西，比如比尔·盖茨如何把他一年要读的所有书，你知道，
sprites off into the woods and reads them like in solitude, which is if you like, yeah, that's a little too extreme. He's a billionaire. So I can't hate. That's not something right. Yeah.
带到树林里，独自阅读，如果你喜欢，是的，那有点太极端了。他是亿万富翁。所以我不能恨他。那不是什么，没错。是的。
You know, maybe here's something to going into the woods for a week with every book you're going to read and then coming out like all this knowledge. I don't know. Like, you know, he makes more money than me, so I can, i can you know i think it's i think it's a weird flex but okay but you know whatever um like that the idea of deep work being at home where you're already comfortable you're able to do that deep work with little to no you know interruption or maybe go to like a co-work space if you have to like i'm one of those people where like i am half and half where like i have to be cut off but i like don't have
你知道，也许去树林里待一周，带着你要读的所有书，然后带着所有的知识出来，这有什么意义。我不知道。他赚的钱比我多，所以我可以，我认为这是一种奇怪的炫耀，但好吧。但你知道，无论如何，像“深度工作”的想法，在家里，你已经很舒服了，你能够以很少甚至没有干扰的方式进行深度工作，或者如果你必须的话，去一个联合办公空间。我是那种人，我是一半一半，我必须被隔绝，但我不需要
to leave the house like i turn my dining room area into my like work my remote office when i'm at home because i'm like oh i don't invite people over like that anyway why do i need this big space and big table like i don't like people like that yeah i think it's like one of the like great sort of ironies of silicon valley is that you know we built the video conferencing as much as we you know have trouble with it and we make fun of it you know it gets better and better every year and now it's it's so powerful that you can call almost anyone. And yet, you know, everyone's trying to pile into a few cities. But, yeah, I think it will get better. Not only that, our tools are integrating remote work better. Like my favorite app, right, is Visual Studio Code.
离开家。我把餐厅区域变成了我的远程办公室，当我在家的时候，因为我想，反正我也不怎么邀请人过来，为什么我需要这么大的空间和桌子？我不喜欢那样的人。是的，我认为这是硅谷的一大讽刺，我们建立了视频会议，尽管我们对它有意见，我们取笑它，但它每年都在变得越来越好。现在它非常强大，你可以给几乎任何人打电话。然而，每个人都试图挤进几个城市。但是，是的，我认为它会变得更好。不仅如此，我们的工具也在更好地整合远程工作。比如我最喜欢的应用，Visual Studio Code。
Text editor. Super nice. Yeah. Their live share feature now has audio and chat so i don't we can literally just say you know what we're going to shut zoom down everybody go to this live share and we are going to talk and chat while pairing wait what is i don't know about this you can actually uh like stream yourself coding? Is that what this is?
文本编辑器。超级好用。是的。他们的 Live Share 功能现在有音频和聊天功能，所以我们甚至不需要，我们可以直接说，你知道吗，我们要关掉 Zoom，大家都去这个 Live Share，我们可以在结对编程的同时交谈和聊天。等等，什么？我不知道这个。你真的可以，像，直播你自己编程？这就是这个吗？
Yes, everybody can jump on LiveShare and pair together while talking at the same time. Like, it's amazing. Like, it's like, I don't know. It's, I don't know. It's the best thing since peanut butter and jelly. Let's put it together. Patrick and I, we're going to have to go on Twitch. And maybe the three of us. The three of us are going us have to go on twitch and stream ourselves making something crazy it's the most like i absolutely
是的，每个人都可以跳进 Live Share，在交谈的同时一起结对编程。这太神奇了。这就像，我不知道。这是自花生酱和果酱以来最好的东西。让我们把它放在一起。帕特里克和我，我们得去 Twitch。也许我们三个。我们三个得去 Twitch，直播我们制作一些疯狂的东西。这是最，我绝对
love it my like yo i just used it today and i was like man what a time to be alive like no no having to use skype or zoom at the same time or even if you're in slack right you can now from slack let's jump on a call. And you just press the call feature in Slack. And then, you know, there you are. Yeah, I'm calling Slack. Okay, this is nice. All right, now I have to fire up another app.
喜欢它。我今天刚用过，我当时想，伙计，多么美好的时代。不需要同时使用 Skype 或 Zoom，甚至如果你在 Slack 里，你现在可以从 Slack 直接发起通话。你只需按下 Slack 中的通话功能。然后，你就到了。是的，我正在给 Slack 打电话。好吧，这很好。现在我得启动另一个应用。
Like the app companies have decided, the services have, you know, like made it so that it's so much easier for us to integrate the idea of being human and human interaction into our work right because in the end that's what the thing was missing with being a programmer right because people tend to think especially the more collegiate style programmers they program for computers when the secret is we supposed to program for humans to understand programming not for the computer because the computer is going to compile and run it regardless so you might as well you know code for the person that's going to come after you right computer doesn't care yeah there's a saying that uh you know um if your code gets peer-reviewed which you know if you're on any sort of team that's
应用公司已经决定，服务已经使我们更容易将人类和人类互动的想法融入到我们的工作中，因为归根结底，这就是作为程序员所缺失的东西。因为人们倾向于认为，特别是那些学院派程序员，他们为计算机编程，而秘密在于我们应该为人类理解编程而编程，而不是为计算机，因为计算机无论如何都会编译和运行它。所以你最好为之后接手的人编写代码。计算机不在乎。是的，有一句谚语说，如果你的代码经过同行评审，如果你在任何团队中，
going to happen, then right off the bat, it's been read by twice as many people that have written it. So you wrote it, but two people have read it. And that's before it even goes into the repository. You know, chances are hundreds, maybe thousands of people are going to read it after that. Yeah. And, you know, that's the, you know, that's the secret sauce of programming, right? Programming for human interaction and not for the computer because computer doesn't care right um so but we did we not get off on like a crazy tangent we're talking about trying tips for like people that are in college i think you know i think you you had a really good point which was you know to find out you know sort of what your passion is. One of the ways that I've sort of discovered the things that I, um, are really passionate about is, is do I kind of, is it something that I can do till two in the morning and I'm still
这都会发生，那么它被阅读的次数是编写它的次数的两倍。你写了它，但有两个人读了它。这甚至在它进入仓库之前。你知道，很有可能成百上千，甚至成千上万的人会在那之后阅读它。是的，这就是编程的秘诀，对吧？为人类互动而编程，而不是为计算机，因为计算机不在乎。所以，我们是不是跑题了？我们是在谈论给大学里的人的建议。我认为你有一个很好的观点，那就是找到你热衷的事情。我发现我真正热衷的事情的方法之一是，我是否可以做到凌晨两点，我仍然
kind of excited. I have to kind of force myself to go to bed. And there are things, uh, that, that, that bring that out of me, but they're not valuable. Like playing video games. I could easily play video games till four in the morning, but so can everyone else. And so I can't, that's of me, but they're not valuable. Like playing video games. I could easily play video games till four in the morning, but so can everyone else. And so I can't, that's not a skill that's really like marketable, right? But honestly, like solving puzzles. I don't know, esports, like they have,
有点兴奋。我不得不强迫自己去睡觉。有些事情能激发我的这种状态，但它们没有价值。比如玩电子游戏。我可以轻松地玩到凌晨四点，但其他人也可以。所以我不能，那不是一种真正有市场价值的技能，对吧？但老实说，解决难题。我不知道，电子竞技，他们有，
the first high school esports team just opened up. The Air Force has an esports team now. And then there's a college, like colleges have esports teams i am also that one dude who cannot do more than like 30 40 minutes of gaming because if i do like i get bored like there's no video game it's gonna keep me up game for an hour i'm like hell i don't get it like my friends they make fun of me like i can't stay on a game for three four hours so i'm like you guys like when do you guys go outside like when do you guys go to movies like i'm a movie guy i'm a bruncher like i want to go like i have my instagram to do with food i don't know anything like like i'll go outside and like i want to eat at that cool new place or i
第一支高中电子竞技队刚刚成立。空军现在也有电子竞技队。还有大学，大学也有电子竞技队。我也是那种玩游戏超过 30 到 40 分钟就受不了的人，因为如果我玩，我会感到无聊。没有电子游戏能让我熬夜玩一个小时，我心想，见鬼，我不明白。我的朋友们取笑我，我无法在游戏上待三四个小时。我心想，你们什么时候出去？你们什么时候去看电影？我是个电影迷，我喜欢早午餐，我想去，我有我的 Instagram 来记录食物。我不知道任何事，我会出去，我想在那家很酷的新店吃饭，或者我
want to go to like Cheekwood, like, like understand my city. Oh, there's an Indian spot there. Indian before let's go there. I'm like, I'm a fat kid. Like I love cake. My parents are, are, are the same way. Like my parents love to just take me out when I was little on, on drives around the town. And I'd always think this is so dumb. Like we would just, we would just drive around the town looking i'd always think this is so dumb like we would just we would just drive around the town looking for a restaurant uh you know that we hadn't been to and and uh we lived in in uh
想去像 Cheekwood 这样的地方，了解我的城市。哦，那里有一家印度餐馆。去那里吧。我像个胖孩子。我喜欢蛋糕。我的父母也是一样。我的父母在我小时候喜欢带我开车兜风。我总是觉得这太蠢了。我们只是开车在城里转悠，寻找一家
you know we also lived in the south and so we'd go to random cities we'd go to places that were like really out there in the boonies we'd eat at restaurants where people would look at us pretty weird because it's just these like like Italian people just kind of show up at like a biker bar. But my parents, that was their thing. They could just drive around looking at different restaurants and stuff. And that gave them a lot of energy. So a lot of people feel like they need to find that one thing, that one dream job or dream strength. But it really doesn't work that way. I think,
我们没去过的餐馆。我们住在南方，所以我们会去随机的城市，去那些非常偏远的地方。我们在餐馆吃饭，人们会用很奇怪的眼光看我们，因为这就像意大利人出现在摩托车酒吧里。但我的父母，那是他们的爱好。他们可以开车到处寻找不同的餐馆。这给了他们很多能量。所以很多人觉得他们需要找到那唯一的一件事，那唯一的一份梦想工作或梦想优势。但它真的不是那样运作的。我认为，
you know, you actually, any person out there has a lot of strengths, a lot of things that they could do that would that would be very fulfilling for them. And it's really just finding out like overlaying that on top of the market, because you have the market, you know, good, bad, it's not going to change. I'd love to live in a world where everyone spent you know 20k a year on art and they got 20k a year of value out of it and our artists could be doing great but the market is what it is like we can't change it right so so like look at the sort of things that you could bring to the table and look at the market and say is there you know where is that overlap where i could do the job that i would be doing for free but also make great money?
你实际上，任何一个人都有很多优势，很多他们可以做的事情，这些事情对他们来说会非常充实。这真的只是找到它，并将其叠加在市场上，因为市场，你知道，好坏，它不会改变。我希望能生活在一个每个人每年花 2 万美元在艺术上，并从中获得 2 万美元价值的世界里，我们的艺术家可以做得很好，但市场就是这样，我们无法改变它。所以，看看你能带来什么，看看市场，问问自己，重叠在哪里？我可以在做这份工作的同时，做我本来会免费做的事情，还能赚到大钱吗？
Yeah. I mean, going back to that analogy of loving video games, being able to build the games that you would love to play, that's where that – or fashion. I know so many people – I don't know if you guys ever heard of Ken Wheeler. Ken Wheeler is my favorite person. No, I haven't heard of him. Yeah, Ken, A, because Ken is like two steps to the left of crazy. Like it's my first favorite place. I don't know the reason.
是的。回到热爱电子游戏的比喻，能够构建你喜欢玩的游戏，这就是——或者时尚。我知道很多人——我不知道你们有没有听说过 Ken Wheeler。Ken Wheeler 是我最喜欢的人。不，我没听说过他。是的，Ken，第一，因为 Ken 离疯狂只有两步之遥。这是我第一个最喜欢的地方。我不知道原因。
But he has this really storied history of being a high school dropout and then going back and trying to go to college and trying to be a rapper and having all these things that he loved but like failed but found himself learning javascript and becoming really really good at it and now you know he's a developer expert and there's all these things but you would never believe that when you're right looking at his code this is some you know dude that one day wanted to be like eminem like for real like like you look like when you talk to him you're like oh yeah because i make fun of him like oh you know sunglasses you look a little bit like pitbull like it's kind of weird but you know it's just those are those are the things like you know i have a colleague uh she's really she was really big into fashion before she ended up getting into data science.
但他有一段非常传奇的历史，高中辍学，然后回去尝试上大学，尝试成为一名说唱歌手，拥有所有他热爱但失败了的东西，但他发现自己学习了 JavaScript，并变得非常非常擅长。现在他是一名开发专家，有很多成就，但当你看着他的代码时，你永远不会相信这是一个曾经想成为像 Eminem 那样的人。真的，当你和他交谈时，你会想“哦，是的”，因为我取笑他，“哦，你知道，戴着墨镜，你看起来有点像 Pitbull”，这有点奇怪。但你知道，这就是那些事情。我有一个同事，她在进入数据科学之前非常热衷于时尚。
And it was that using, like, fashion and fashion trends that, you know, really helped her focus on that track of data science. So, like, you know, food, I think that helped me with design, like, and learning, like, color psychology and stuff. Because, you know, like, food, different foods, it was different vibrancies and, because you know like food different foods it was different vibrancies and like things like that like when you're talking about your parents uh try driving all over the place looking for restaurants is why you know you get to learn different things about your city just through the food like you know nashville is famous for its hot chicken right everybody talks about natural hot chicken people never talk about the fact that nashville is also famous for maxwell house coffee because that's my maxwell hot house is literally here uh i have a buddy from nashville who says uh the ribs
正是利用时尚和时尚趋势，真正帮助她专注于数据科学的轨道。所以，食物，我认为这帮助了我进行设计，学习色彩心理学之类的东西。因为，你知道，食物，不同的食物，它有不同的活力，当你谈论你的父母开车到处寻找餐馆时，这就是为什么你通过食物了解了关于你城市的不同事物。你知道，纳什维尔以其热炸鸡闻名，对吧？每个人都在谈论纳什维尔热炸鸡，人们从不谈论纳什维尔也以麦斯威尔咖啡闻名，因为麦斯威尔咖啡就在这里。我有一个纳什维尔的朋友说，排骨
like you know i have a big fan of texas ribs and he just told me i can't be your friend anymore like he said natural ribs are magic he is lying like don't listen to him. You can't be his friend because he's lying to you. Oh, no, it's Memphis. Sorry, he said Memphis. Yeah, okay. Memphis ribs are the best. Yeah, Memphis ribs are, like, Memphis for ribs, Texas for pulled pork, South Carolina, just don't even go for the barbecue. It's weird. But, like, Nashville is also, we have a bar here.
我是德州排骨的忠实粉丝，他刚告诉我，我不能再做你的朋友了，他说纳什维尔排骨是魔法。他在撒谎，别听他的。你不能做他的朋友，因为他在对你撒谎。哦，不，是孟菲斯。抱歉，他说的是孟菲斯。是的，好吧。孟菲斯排骨是最好的。是的，孟菲斯排骨是，孟菲斯排骨，德州手撕猪肉，南卡罗来纳州，甚至不要去那里吃烧烤。这很奇怪。但是，纳什维尔也有，我们这里有一家酒吧。
Like, not a bar bar. It's a cotton candy bar because Nashville is the home of the creation of cotton candy. And, you know, like things like that, like, oh, man, it's such a huge thing to like feed your creative juices and like keep you going. Like that's like things for me to help me like learn more about UI and history. I'm like I'm all over the place when it comes to front-end development and how for me, food and cooking, this year has been this secret of focusing on food science for me, and I've been learning more about development and programming through cooking because focusing on serious eats and food lab and temperatures and like what
不是那种酒吧。它是棉花糖吧，因为纳什维尔是棉花糖的发源地。你知道，像这样的事情，哦，天哪，这对于滋养你的创造力并让你继续前进是非常重要的事情。这对我来说是帮助我学习更多 UI 和历史的事情。在前端开发方面，我无处不在，对我来说，食物和烹饪，今年对我来说是专注于食品科学的秘密，我通过烹饪学习了更多关于开发和编程的知识，因为专注于 Serious Eats 和 Food Lab 以及温度，以及什么
meat you could cook with this or if you're going pescatarian, what type of fish are best for this type of dish and vegetables and stuff like that and like mastery of having to make ramen and like... Do you post about this on your Twitter?
肉可以用这个烹饪，或者如果你是鱼素者，哪种鱼最适合这种菜肴和蔬菜之类的东西，以及必须制作拉面的精通……你会把这些发到你的 Twitter 上吗？
Do you post like some of your best recipes, things you've cooked? I am on the Instagram. Oh, Instagram, okay. Yeah, my personal Instagram is Captain America, my puppy, and my food. You would think I'm just a Captain America fan who has a dog who likes food. That's pretty much all that's on like my Instagram. So what about like people who want to know more about,
你会发布一些你最好的食谱，你做过的东西吗？我在 Instagram 上。哦，Instagram，好的。是的，我的个人 Instagram 是美国队长，我的小狗，还有我的食物。你会以为我只是一个喜欢食物的养狗的美国队长粉丝。我的 Instagram 上基本上只有这些。那么关于那些想了解更多关于
you know, about you, your experience, Vets Who Code, these kinds of things. How can people kind of reach out? Should they follow your Twitter? You know,
你，你的经历，Vets Who Code，这些事情的人。人们怎么联系？他们应该关注你的 Twitter 吗？你知道，
how would, how can people keep up to date with what's going on? I don't really tweet about VWC stuff and JavaScript on Twitter. So, at Jerome Hardaway on Twitter, at Betsy Code on Twitter, the Betsy Code website. I'm a pretty much open book when it comes to that on Twitter
人们怎么能跟上正在发生的事情？我真的不在 Twitter 上发关于 VWC 和 JavaScript 的东西。所以，Twitter 上是 @JeromeHardaway，Twitter 上是 @VetsWhoCode，还有 Vets Who Code 网站。在 Twitter 上，我基本上是一个公开透明的人
as well. I love having conversations. When it comes to people that want to help, we have certain protocols. We try to make sure that people who are mentors, they have at least two years of experience in the industry, either in JavaScript or something else. And when it comes to people touching our product,
。我喜欢交流。当涉及到想要提供帮助的人时，我们有特定的协议。我们尽量确保导师在行业内至少有两年的经验，无论是 JavaScript 还是其他领域。当涉及到人们接触我们的产品时，
we kind of only need the product for the veterans because if you get a ticket, then it's going to keep a veteran from getting a ticket. Yeah, the best way to be part of that course is to build the next course, right? Or to build something and have it go in production. Every time a troop
我们基本上只需要退伍军人来做产品，因为如果你拿走了一个工单，那就会阻止一名退伍军人获得工单。是的，参与该课程的最好方式是构建下一门课程，对吧？或者构建一些东西并让它投入生产。每当一名学员
builds something in production, a drill sergeant gets his wings. That's right. Maybe a drill sergeant loses his voice. Maybe we should do that one. But that's what people really want. Yeah, so those are like certain prerogatives, priorities,
在生产环境中构建东西时，一名教官就会获得他的勋章。没错。也许教官会失去他的声音。也许我们应该做那个。但这就是人们真正想要的。是的，所以这些是特定的特权，优先级，
but we're always looking for people who, you know, you fit that criteria, particularly in JavaScript, when it comes to ES6, things like that, pure JavaScript, the nuts and bolts. Like, we're always looking for people who have that experience. Very cool. Now that the podcast has been going for a while, we definitely
但我们一直在寻找符合这些标准的人，特别是在 JavaScript 方面，当涉及到 ES6 之类的东西，纯 JavaScript，核心内容时。我们一直在寻找有这种经验的人。非常酷。既然播客已经进行了一段时间了，我们肯定
have folks who have been in their career for years. Obviously, there's people who even listen to us from the beginning who are career professionals. If any of you out there have a strong background in JavaScript, this is an amazing opportunity to sort of give back, right? And to, you know,
有些听众在各自的职业生涯中已经工作多年了。显然，甚至从一开始就听我们节目的听众中也有职业人士。如果你们中间有谁在 JavaScript 方面有深厚的背景，这是一个非常好的回馈机会，对吧？而且，你知道，
you can never underestimate sort of like how important it is to have reciprocity, right? I mean, every time you give something, you always get something back. So if you have that experience, definitely. Personally, I'm absolutely terrible at building websites. I'll be honest. I think it's an amazing skill to have sort of that ability to kind of lay everything out kind of in your mind. You know, also the whole that full stack client server, all of that. But I think if you're out there and you have that skill, this is just a really amazing opportunity. You know, hit up Jerome on Twitter
你永远不能低估互惠的重要性，对吧？我的意思是，每次你付出一些东西，你总会得到一些回报。所以如果你有那样的经验，一定要参与。就我个人而言，我在构建网站方面真的很糟糕。说实话，我认为能够把所有东西在脑海中规划出来是一种了不起的技能。你知道，还有全栈、客户端、服务器等等。但我认为如果你有这种技能，这真的是一个非常棒的机会。你知道，在 Twitter 上联系 Jerome
and tell him, you know, hey, I want to be a mentor. You know, I want to try and help out. And, you know, I want to teach the next generation. And I think in that way, you could really contribute. Raj, yeah, that's the best way. We're always looking for people
告诉他，嘿，我想成为一名导师。我想尝试提供帮助。我想教导下一代。我认为通过这种方式，你可以做出真正的贡献。Raj，是的，那是最好的方式。我们一直在寻找那些
who are willing to help the next generation of veterans learn JavaScript. It's like you said that, you know, giving back gives, you know, when you teach, you become a better, you become better at what you're teaching and, you know, for that person that's learning that helps them build their confidence. Like that's where the whole, you know, I matter come from. Like someone's, you know, someone's investing in me and then, you know,
愿意帮助下一代退伍军人学习 JavaScript 的人。就像你说的，回馈社会，当你教书时，你会变得更好，你所教的内容也会变得更好，而且对于正在学习的那个人来说，这有助于建立他们的自信心。这就是“我很重要”这种感觉的来源。就像有人在投资我，然后，你知道，
veterans are weird like that. Like they need to know that people are investing in me and you know veterans are weird like that like they need to know that people are investing in them and depending on them for them to like you know like get serious like i think it's coming from the military where you're accustomed to dealing with that stress of like having the world on your shoulders like oh yes like if you mess up at work the missiles don't go down or people don't come back home. Hey, it's the reality of the beast, right? I have a buddy who was in the military, and he was saying he set up Microsoft Exchange, the email servers.
退伍军人就是这样。他们需要知道人们在投资他们，并且依赖他们，这样他们才能认真起来。我想这源于军队生活，你习惯了处理那种肩负重任的压力。比如，如果你在工作中搞砸了，导弹就不会发射，或者人们就回不了家。嘿，这就是现实，对吧？我有个朋友在军队服役，他说他负责设置 Microsoft Exchange，即电子邮件服务器。
He set them up on FOBs, on Forward Operating Bases. Yeah, FOBS. FOBS, yeah. And he said – I asked him what it was like, and he said, well, just imagine, you know, trying to set up someone's email, but there's bombs landing. It's like, wow.
他在前线作战基地（FOB）设置了这些服务器。是的，FOB。FOB，没错。他说——我问他那是什么感觉，他说，嗯，想象一下，你试图帮别人设置电子邮件，但炸弹就在旁边爆炸。这真是太震撼了。
It's like all these things. The way he said it, it was very short, but it really kind of created sort of cognitive distance, like put everything in perspective, you know. Yeah, we were, one of my exes, we were going through a first aid course together. But I already went through like a combat lifesaver course like years ago. And I was just flying through it and doing well.
就像所有这些事情一样。他说话的方式很简短，但确实创造了一种认知距离，让一切都变得清晰起来。是的，我们，我的一个前任，我们一起参加过急救课程。但我几年前就已经参加过战斗救生员课程了。所以我学得很快，表现也很好。
And she was mad at me about it. Because like we just wanted to go through this CPR first aid thing because my nieces and nephews are coming over. Spending a week with me. Oh, my goodness. Like the military did not train me for that. So I was making fun of her. And I was like everything you can do i can do a boss dropping over dropping over me and she was like just shut up jerome i was like oh okay i'm shut up now so uh you know that's awesome so yeah there patrick's laughing
她对此很生气。因为我们只是想学习心肺复苏术和急救，因为我的侄子侄女要过来。要和我待上一周。天哪。军队可没教过我怎么应付那个。所以我取笑她，我说“你能做的我都能做得更好”，她就说“闭嘴吧 Jerome”，我说“哦好的，我现在闭嘴”。所以，这太棒了，Patrick 也在笑。
oh man that's awesome well thank you so much for for your time this is absolutely amazing um i really i know there's a lot of strong javascript developers who listen to the show i really encourage all of y'all to reach out to jerome um let us know if if if uh um if you had any other questions for him or anything like that and we tried to cover all the ones that came our way. But you could also just reach out to Jerome directly. He's very accessible. Yeah, I like giving the tools and things. I'm going on a journey right now called JavaScript De-Fatigue
天哪，这太棒了。非常感谢你抽出时间，这绝对太棒了。我知道有很多强大的 JavaScript 开发人员在听这个节目，我真的鼓励你们所有人联系 Jerome。让我们知道你们是否还有其他问题，我们尽量涵盖了所有收到的问题。但你也可以直接联系 Jerome。他非常容易沟通。是的，我喜欢提供工具和资源。我现在正在进行一段名为“JavaScript 去疲劳”的旅程，
because there's so many resources out there that you can learn from. So I am going to focus on one year, only this one resource and only the resources that are recommended from this one resource. And I am documenting my skills based upon that. Like, hey, I'm only doing one thing and the only things that come from this thing.
因为外面有太多的资源可以学习。所以我打算专注于一年，只用这一个资源，并且只学习这个资源推荐的内容。我正在根据这个来记录我的技能。比如，嘿，我只做一件事，而且只做这件事带来的东西。
And I'm going to tell you guys my experience from that so like you know especially with javascript developers i love javascript developers like people are looking to get into javascript like tweet me i'll send you like i'll let you know what stuff you need to but oh focus on this don't focus on that learn this don't learn that it's cool like especially front ends love front ends front ends. So if you're wanting to, like, I feel like there's no more rewarding industry than front end development, because in the end, no matter how intricate the back end is, or how big the data set is, or how detailed the data set is, you know, people aren't going to care if it doesn't look pretty, right? Like, that's just how people are.
我会告诉你们我的经验，特别是对于 JavaScript 开发人员，我喜欢 JavaScript 开发人员。如果有人想进入 JavaScript 领域，请在 Twitter 上联系我，我会告诉你需要什么，专注于这个，不要关注那个，学习这个，不要学习那个。这很酷，特别是前端，我喜欢前端。所以如果你想的话，我觉得没有比前端开发更有回报的行业了，因为最终，无论后端多么复杂，或者数据集有多大，或者数据集有多详细，你知道，如果它看起来不漂亮，人们是不会关心的，对吧？这就是人们的本性。
Like, Facebook is one of the most like you know when you look at the machine learning and stuff that goes on like it's insane but didn't get there because machine learning got there because people liked the experience ahead with the app right so because that's how in the end people have to like things and people haven't want to look at it right same way with any you know clothes cars anything else that's the web so like it's like you know you're always going you're the it's like being a gate guard or elite gate guard in the military you're the first line of defense you're the first thing that the peak that the person is going to see and like so you have to you have to bring it because your job how would
就像 Facebook，当你看到机器学习等内容时，这很疯狂，但它之所以成功并不是因为机器学习，而是因为人们喜欢使用该应用程序的体验，对吧？因为最终人们必须喜欢这些东西，人们必须想看它，对吧？任何衣服、汽车或其他东西都是如此，网络也是一样。所以你总是处于前线，就像军队里的守门员或精英守门员一样，你是第一道防线，你是人们第一眼看到的东西，所以你必须全力以赴，因为你的工作如何，
you were how well you will be doing your job depends on the how hard the other guys have to work right so like you know yeah i mean you can you can have a bad first impression and say well that and that that was really unfortunate but then the next day you're meeting somebody else but if you have a bad website, your whole company could be gone. Oh, yeah. I recently found a website that was so bad, I almost volunteered to do the site for her. Because I loved her Instagram, the product she was selling. I loved her Instagram.
你工作做得有多好，取决于其他人必须付出多大的努力，对吧？所以，是的，我的意思是，你可能会给人留下糟糕的第一印象，并说那真的很不幸，但第二天你又会遇到别人。但如果你有一个糟糕的网站，你的整个公司可能就完了。哦，是的。我最近发现一个网站太糟糕了，我差点自愿为她做网站。因为我喜欢她的 Instagram，她卖的产品。我喜欢她的 Instagram。
I was like, yo, I'm going to buy some of this for my lady because she's going to love this stuff. I went to the website and said, I'm not putting my credit card in this this was like that bad name on Spongebob not going to do that alright well thank you so much for coming on the show it's at Jerome Hardaway
我当时想，哟，我要为我的女士买一些，因为她会喜欢这些东西的。我去了那个网站，说，我不会把我的信用卡信息输入到这里。这就像海绵宝宝里的那个坏名字，我不会那样做的。好的，非常感谢你来到节目，账号是 @JeromeHardaway
does Vets Who Code have a Twitter or is that the same one at Vets Who Code have a Twitter or is that the same one? At Vets Who Code. Cool. The website is VetsWhoCode.io, GitHub repo and GitHub organizations, Vets Who Code. We're starting two new projects that the troops are going
Vets Who Code 有 Twitter 吗，还是同一个账号？@VetsWhoCode。酷。网站是 VetsWhoCode.io，GitHub 仓库和 GitHub 组织是 Vets Who Code。我们正在启动两个新项目，部队成员将
to start working on. So if you're looking for hiring troops, just check out or people for speaking in organizations or anything opportunities, anything, you'll be looking at the vetswho.codes. That's going to be one project we're rolling out and then we're rolling out our vetswho.code.github.io
开始参与工作。所以如果你正在寻找招聘部队成员，或者寻找演讲组织或任何机会，请查看 vetswho.codes。这将是我们推出的一个项目，然后我们正在推出我们的 vetswho.code.github.io
so that way people will be able to keep up with projects and things that we're doing in the organization without having to look at GitHub. We have a lot of things rolling and coming down the pipeline. Very exciting.. We have a lot of things rolling and coming down the pipeline. So very exciting. Very cool. Cool.
这样人们就能够跟上我们在组织中正在做的项目和事情，而不必查看 GitHub。我们有很多事情正在进行中。非常令人兴奋。我们有很多事情正在进行中。所以非常令人兴奋。非常酷。酷。
Thanks a lot. And thanks, everyone, for subscribing on Patreon, subscribing on Audible, using our Audible link to get that. I hope you really enjoyed this interview. I definitely did. I learned a ton about JavaScript. I learned a lot about military service and what that's like. Thank you again
非常感谢。也感谢大家在 Patreon 上订阅，在 Audible 上订阅，并使用我们的 Audible 链接。我希望你们真的很喜欢这次采访。我确实很喜欢。我学到了很多关于 JavaScript 的知识。我也学到了很多关于服兵役以及那是什么样的经历。再次感谢
for coming on the show, Jerome. Thank you all for listening. Catch you next month. Thank you guys for having me. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons
你来到节目，Jerome。感谢大家的收听。下个月见。谢谢你们邀请我。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 是在知识共享协议下分发的
Attribution ShareAlike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可协议。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传播该作品，进行混音、改编，但你必须注明 Patrick 和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。